hey guys pete here we're going to try
something new today
welcome to the saturday better call saul
stream we're going to look forward this
time and i've invited some friends to
come talk about episode 10
which does look like it's going to be
called nippy it looks like that stuck
that that's the actual title it seemed
like it might have been a placeholder at
one time
and where we think this show might take
us in the last four episodes because
i think it's exciting that it's really
hard to say i mean we were just talking
about this off screen and
for as much time as i have
invested in this uh you know these two
series and and thinking about them and
talking about them
we're really at a place where it is you
know anything could happen
and we got the prequel aspects they're
mostly wrapped up
there's not a lot there's really not
much more story that needs to be told in
the
better call saul timeline and um
we got the overlap with the original
series we're going to spend some time
there we know that for sure
and then the sequel part which is going
to give us the ending i mean as far as
we know right now this will be the last
thing we see that takes place inside the
breaking bad universe so
a lot of there's a lot to talk about i
think and um
i'm gonna let all of my guests sort of
give us none of them were on the tuesday
stream when we talked about episode nine
so
i'm going to give everyone a chance to
you know tell us who they are
talk about their channels and you know
what they're doing and
a brief uh
you know a brief synopsis of what they
thought of episode nine and then we'll
just uh you know move into
what happens next so
courtney you're the next window down
below me why don't you go first and
introduce yourself sure hey i'm courtney
from courtney's reviews
and uh what i thought about this episode
it was heartbreaking and a viewer
actually commented and i thought it was
like the perfect description of this
episode and adam said that it's possibly
the only episode that he enjoyed every
minute of but also found um like
excruciating and hated every second of
it and i thought yeah that's that's
that's pretty accurate
it kind of sums up how i felt too i
thought it was great it really was one
of the best in my opinion but man was it
brutal
brutal is a word that i would use and um
you know it it
i i've been looking at comments this
morning when i woke up from from my last
video and um
i i i see some people had problems but i
think universally even if you didn't
think it was an enjoyable episode or you
didn't get what you wanted to happen or
whatever i think it's you know pretty
universally
considered to be one of the strongest uh
episodes and i i would say i mean i'm
i'm coming from a place of have having
just been
you know recency you know like i just
saw it it it affected me
quite a bit uh but right now to me it
seems like the best episode of the
series where do you think about like how
did it land for you and as far as like
you know was it one of your favorites or
what did you think
uh yeah it's definitely up there i think
this the last three episodes i see it as
an arc you know from howard to lalo to
to this one and as a resolution to all
of these these storylines so
um it's hard for me at this point to
rate them because uh but i would
definitely put it up there i would put
it up there in top five for sure
yeah i i really loved it um
let's move on to eric eric you want to
introduce yourself
thank you uh sure um i'm eric from um
inside the gilliverse and music care
network and for those of you that don't
know we talk about better cross hall and
break it bad and all that stuff on on my
channel and
uh thank you for the love for my channel
as well too i appreciate it and um yeah
um
um i watched the show again just again
just about 15 20 minutes before uh
you know jumping on live here tonight
just to freshen myself up and i think
i've watched it maybe five times since
uh it aired
and it is a really powerful episode uh
very very powerful
um and i'm anxious to talk about some of
the things that were said in it you know
because i'll share something i've had a
long theory since like the very first
season and it proved to be true
um in this episode so i'll be happy to
share my thoughts on that but um it's
it's very powerful and um i can just say
wow like it's it's i think the re replay
value on that episode is maybe one of
the best of the uh of the series
yeah i would agree there
and chase why don't you round out the uh
guest introductions
yeah for sure so hey guys kiwi here also
known as chase um as far as episode 609
goes now while initially watching it i
was getting some 604 to 606 vibes in
regards to the pacing of the first half
that a half of the episode on the cartel
side but i gotta agree with what eric
said in regards to the rewatch ability
for this episode because every time i've
gone back and rewatched it i've enjoyed
it more and more and i do think that the
second half of the episode uh is
stronger than the first half or at least
i initially did but going back i really
gained appreciation for the whole uh you
know the gus drinking wine scene and
everything to do with that and then um i
loved how we got kind of a conclusion
with nacho's father and then hhm's final
stand was absolutely wild it was kind of
depressing knowing that you know it's
the end of an era uh metaphorically and
literally but then
going into the breakup scene like my jaw
just dropped and i'm really happy that
we got the confrontation uh with kim
admitting that she knew that lala was
still alive and
and then i guess yeah the the saw time
skip was was really good it really ended
episode on a high note i was not
expecting that i was expecting some
breaking bad stuff and maybe episode 10
or 11 but i was not expecting that time
jump in episode nine so that that was
really awesome um as far as uh i was
kind of thinking uh when you asked like
you know where where would we rate this
episode i'm not sure if i'd rate it top
five uh just because there's so many
good ones definitely top ten though um
it really really felt like an epilogue
to the whole better call cell timeline
and yeah just i've definitely grown
grown a lot more appreciation for this
episode throughout the week i mean i
still liked it when i watched it but
yeah just watching it over and over and
breaking down all the all the different
scenes uh yeah i just i i really do
enjoy it and i like the i'm really
interested in the direction we're headed
because yeah we almost have next to no
idea what's going to happen next so
there's a lot of theories we can talk
about here
yeah and i think one of the things that
makes it uh you know so high on
so high on my list is that you know this
is something that we had poured over you
know especially us but fans in general
you know how this might play out and
you know whenever we were going into it
there was just none i didn't like any of
the options for how this relationship
would would end and and what would
happen as far as kim leaving his life
you know it all felt really inevitable
but
you know none of the none of the
the popular theories especially at this
part of the season you know after we had
had had seen things develop for for
eight episodes you know none of it
really felt like it fit
and i just thought it was so impressive
and and the way that they they actually
wrapped that up and and you know like i
said i didn't i wasn't happy about it it
you know it kind of
it's kind of a bummer and and it
definitely will get into the fact just
how much it changes
you know the breaking bad experience um
knowing some of these things but i mean
i just thought it was a super impressive
way to uh wrap these things up and you
know that that's part of what makes it
exciting you know you know going forward
is like okay well they picked this as
their spot to
you know
basically end the first series and now
they're going to move into the sequel i
guess and you know
it it definitely has me excited to see
you know what they have what they have
dreamed up for that
i wanted to do i see i have some uh
super chats and i am going to get to
those but i did want to do one quick
question
for everyone um
it's i want to talk about this idea of
the first i love you and the last you
know that was said on screen i saw an
article or an interview with ray c horn
that alan seppenwald did and she said
that she thought that jimmy and kim say
i love you often off screen and you know
that sounded good to me whenever i read
it i thought that made sense and then
writer producer thomas schnauz who is
eric's uh co-host over there on
inside the gila verse he tweeted out
that his opinion was that this was the
first time they said it
but he also you know added that he
thinks that they show their affection in
different ways they just hadn't said it
out loud um
so i just wondered what you guys thought
like which which which do you like
better is this the first time that that
uh jimmy mcgill ever said i love you to
kim wexler
or do you think that they said it all
the time and this is just
him you know
bringing it up and it you know to to
just really underline the point that hey
look at me here i'm i'm leaving it you
know this is me
you know raw without anything else um
just this is the only thing there's left
to say
you can go first courtney
uh i kind of like tom's version
a little bit more than i think than race
but i can certainly see them behind the
scenes saying it but i think that they
demonstrate their affection for each
other in other ways you know like the
different um languages of love like you
can do things for for your partner um
demonstrate your affection in other ways
and i i think it's it's unspoken but
they both know
how they feel about each other i don't
think it's something that they
necessarily need to say out loud to
prove
yeah
so you like you like toms what about you
eric um i don't think my personal
opinion is i don't and this is where i
was talking about this theory um my
personal opinion is i don't think they
ever say it i don't they're they're such
a
weird couple
and we don't really get to see
any more of their personal life other
than the way the writers want us to see
it so we don't know what goes on in the
bedroom or in the different scenes and
stuff like that we don't know what goes
on there so we don't know if they're
saying i love you
and
i've always thought since season one um
i wanted i was hoping i'd hear a day
where one of them would say i love you
and then i feared for it at the same
time because i said always that the day
we hear it's going to be a disaster
uh the day we hear them say i love you
it's going to be a disaster and
it was it was complete disaster so i
don't think they say it i think they as
as you guys said too they they this guy
it's implied and um i do think they're
kind of co-dependent on one another as
well too like the characters they they
each need each other but they're like
kim said that they're they're not good
together um i i do think they as much as
we all love them together as a couple
excuse me i think they're they're they
are better apart and i hate to say that
but it's i think it's true
yeah and i think that's one of the one
of the really interesting things they
did when they crafted these characters
is they gave them both a lot of agency
and they're they're able to you know
do a lot of amazing things as
individuals but
they are they're they're kind of
codependent they kind of need each other
and uh that makes things interesting
chase what about you
do they say i love you or not
uh no i'm gonna have to agree with tom
and i guess eric and courtney here i i
do like the idea of this being the first
time that they've said it and almost
hearing them say it it sounds natural
but at the same time it just kind of
sounds strange like for example uh
throughout all the times we've heard uh
from season six and season five uh jimmy
and kim saying oh this is my wife or
this is my husband it's like yeah we
know they're married but every time they
say that it's just like i don't know it
just kind of feels weird to me and i'm
not saying that they aren't in love or
anything like yeah they definitely
show their love and the way that they
care for each other and they have each
other's back and everything and and but
they're not they're not all lovey-dovey
about it right and i think it also
relates back to the whole something
stupid song in regards to the line from
the course i think it goes like and i go
and spoil it all by saying something
stupid like i love you uh that's my
favorite song from the better call solid
soundtrack i have at the top of my
better call sol playlist uh so i think
it relates a lot to the jimmy and kim
relationship especially in their final
moments and i do think that was jimmy
trying to use it as a way to keep them
together but i love how kim says it back
and then deflects it by saying
so what you know because she knows that
that they
they are trouble together and i i really
like how i mean i hate how they had to
end things but it was the best decision
for kim to do so and i'm i'm at least
glad that she she lives through it you
know
yeah and i think those are all all fine
points the the one part that i don't
like about it
about thinking that it's the first time
that they said it to each other is that
he's
he's basically pleading there you know
what i mean and
and
it's not the uh
i don't know i mean when you watch the
scene
like i said i think he kind of
i think he kind of he kind of steps back
and he realizes like you know what's
actually happening in real time like you
do whenever you know whenever you're
faced with a conversation like this
and i think you know he he's letting
himself be vulnerable there and
you know when you when you see the way
that he delivers it it is sort of like
he's he's saying look
you know i hear what you're saying but
but come on i love you and um i don't
know i i just think that
it's not the best but um
it could go either way and uh let's look
at a couple of these super chats here
what do we got um
roger rubio thank you for the five
thank you all for the great breakdowns
to the best show i've ever seen
how would you define a happy ending for
the show
yeah this is a little bit tricky uh
happy is a is a pretty
difficult word to
you know
to to to actually um figure out what
that would be i did a video about this a
few
i guess about a month ago like what
would that even look like
and um oh we lost somebody here
uh but uh one of the things that i think
about whenever i you know
what what would a happy ending look like
i mean
the way that they've set this up this
transformation into saul goodman and
what what jimmy is actually doing you
know the way that he's using this as a
coping mechanism
and you know it it
it looks it's
it's it's in a lot of ways it's darker
than what you could have expected
so part of what a happy ending would be
would be for me like just to see him
reckon with that
and uh you know
redeem himself somehow you know i don't
know what that looks like yet but
that's what i would say what do you guys
think um eric what how how would you
define a happy ending for the show
impossible it's not going to happen
i don't think you can have a happy
ending in this show
i really don't it's uh
i can't see anything happy i mean it's
it's depressing we've lost so many
people um there's a lot of death um and
it's in a lot of cases it's greed cause
you know walter white and everyone
around him
um greed um
it's there's no happy ending i can see
in this show there isn't i mean the hap
i okay okay we say this like everyone
thought kim was gonna die and there's
still some comments in the chat saying
kim's gonna get killed or commit suicide
or things like that
the happy ending is kim will survive in
her own we i think she's going to
survive in her own world so that to me
is happy but it's a depress and that's
the happiest of the most depressing if
that makes any sense i don't see any
happy ending
yeah chase
yeah i think we're going to get a
bittersweet ending i mean i was trying
to think this whole time what would a
happy ending look like but i'm just
trying to
make good of a bad situation you know
with with breaking bad and better call
saul these aren't shows where people get
a happy ending it you know it at the
very most you get a glass has half full
situation where you get to live at the
end of it i mean i would like to think
that maybe gene tackles his paranoia and
doesn't want to live in fear and hiding
anymore what would that look like is he
going gonna go to jail is he gonna turn
himself in is he gonna get caught um
i'm not too sure there but it i mean
just coming out of this situation alive
is
is you know more than anything because
when you look at breaking bad most of
the characters end up dying and now and
better call saul with the final season
we're kind of heading that down that
same road as well so i i feel like kim
has gotten the best ending so far out of
all of our main characters you know all
things considered um yeah i think we're
gonna go bittersweet here um i i think
that's about it i'm not sure i was
trying to think what would a happy
ending look like but i
i don't really think anyone's gonna live
happily ever after here
yeah and just to
to be to be clear the the the question
the he's asking how we would define that
you know so on that scale i think
you guys are both saying like just
living is is is actually kind of happy
compared to what most people get in the
series yes yeah
courtney
yeah i agree with everything that's
already been said um i think a happy
ending in this context would be perhaps
a chance for redemption
for for jimmy so maybe um
because to me the tragedy is how he
becomes saul and i think this uh this
most recent episode really puts an
exclamation point on that fact right
that is the tragedy that is what happens
to him
so perhaps returning to who he really is
will be the happy ending and sort of
facing the music i think it's kind of
what i'm expecting
yeah that's kind of where i'm at too and
you know the other thing that i've been
thinking about a lot since the last
stream because you know we talked about
just the tragedy of
the way that he structured his life to
not to not feel what happened in this
series basically you know to kind of
keep it out of his mind like
what i was what i thought about after
the fact and we kind of touched on it
like how hell not only does it
recontextualize breaking bad
but it also recontextualizes what we've
seen with gene you know when you first
saw gene you see oh he's watching those
those funny commercials from that funny
time of saul goodman you know what i
mean
and now you look at that and you say
what what is he actually doing there
that feels like torture right like if he
if he was really that miserable during
that time period
and you know the
what what dawned on me
between you know over the last couple
days is that
gene is also the antithesis of saul and
that he has none of that stuff like he
has nothing to distract him from from
his thoughts you know what i mean
so i you know i've been
kind of thinking like what what is
actually going through gene's head in
omaha you know now that all the
distractions gone all of all of that
like
it that that'll be really interesting to
see when we get to that time period you
know like what how he's really dealing
with with the weight of all of that and
um
i think that uh
you know it's just it's just a great
trick they did i don't know if you guys
want to add anything to that
uh yeah yeah for sure well uh yeah
gene's obviously been going crazy during
his time in hiding with no one to really
speak to but his own thoughts bouncing
around in his head uh to add on to you
know what you're saying about the first
gene scene we saw him very unhappy
trying to relive his glory days through
those saul goodman commercials and you
know i'm sure you all know this but
that's the only time that we've seen
color in gene's life is the reflection
of the commercial on his glasses and
ever since he's had moments of saul
creeping out through him trying to break
free such as uh in season three when he
yells at that thief to get a lawyer uh
and i think gene's been more focused on
his paranoia than anything i've i've
always wondered is gene's paranoia going
to be his downfall it's been this big
thing i've been wondering about the
whole show because on one hand there's
that saying uh from season six jimmy was
telling kim the wicked flea when no man
pursueth but at the same time gene has a
right to be paranoid due to the
situation he's currently in and jeff you
know having made him kind of validates
his paranoia so
i i think his paranoia has consumed him
during his time as gene and i wonder now
going into season six if he's gonna
tackle his fear in part by dealing with
jeff as he told ed
yeah you yeah eric or courtney do you
want to add anything here
well i think gene is being pursued so uh
he is a wanted man right so i was
actually thinking i'm the line that uh
that kiwi just quoted that the wicked
flea when no man pursue it i think
really fits for kim actually in the most
recent episode they're getting away with
it and yet she chooses
she chooses to flee so as far as as um
what gene is thinking or feeling um i
think he's as as discussed has a lot of
down time to reflect and he's miserable
right
and so i think that moment on the phone
with ed is maybe
the way i read it is that he's tired of
running and he was just in the hospital
right this is starting to have physical
uh repercussions for him right the
stress is so intense and maybe maybe
that's that's it he's just he's ready to
uh hang up the jacket or put the jacket
back on
yeah and that's another thing to think
about is that you know the jacket what
is the jacket symbolize there it's not
it's not
like what we thought when the season
started of just like i'm going to
essentially be jimmy because jimmy is
where the scam comes from right like
whenever you think about
putting saul back on you think about him
doing a scam
but that that's really kind of a weird
misconception um
you know
saul is like running from from reality
you know instead of just being this
really fun guy he's trying to distract
himself from
from you know what's going on inside of
his brain
the game 9205 thank you for the 9.99
love your reviews and breakdowns well i
appreciate that
and
uh it's good we're glad to see you here
thank you
um joe figueroa
five dollars thank you i honestly have a
feeling kim is in some sort of mafia
with the special guest being her
mom
yeah we're gonna get around um
to
i don't know if you're drawing a a
connection with carol burnett here
in general or
just the uh the new player in the game
that they were talking about the i think
the
correct me if i'm wrong but the um
synopsis of this episode was just a new
player enters the game i think and you
know that that seems like it it's about
walt on one level but there could be
another side to it as well
um
what do you think do you think
i guess real quick we'll go around to
everyone what do you think do you think
we're gonna see kim's mom again
not in the uh in the past in the future
yes future mom current mom
you think we're gonna see her in the
future what about you chase
yeah i i would like to honestly i'd like
to see how she's doing if kim can
reconnect with her if they can make
amends or if it's just
estranged forever
courtney yeah agreed actually when i
first heard about carol burnett that was
my first thought it was that she might
play kim's mom i know a lot of people
have issues with the age difference but
i think we can suspend some disbelief
when it comes to ages of the actors a
little bit so um we've been doing it for
years yeah
yeah for sure so i think
i think burnett as as marion wexler or
whatever her last name may be would be
really interesting
hmm
yeah i i don't have a lot of interest in
i'd like to see more about her past and
and courtney you and i have talked about
this quite a bit um i don't i don't
really
i mean i guess i i can see why it might
make sense you know to for her to kind
of reckon with her own
uh background and and where you know
what's where she came from i i don't
know if it's if it's not carol burnett
and carol i mean i kind of want carol
burnett to do something uh
dynamic and i feel like it you know
like to actually you know move the story
and um i don't think that kim's mom will
be the the vehicle for that but
yeah we'll see i guess and we'll come
back around to uh carol burnett too i
think because um
i have a couple other questions that i
would like to get into
and joe figaro uh
figaro sorry two dollars again thank you
he just wanted to say that kiwi your
vids are great
thank you i'm honored i appreciate that
much love
um morty smith thank you for the 199.
pete please read my theory chat or let
me know how to send you
um actually
chase i apologize when you're when you
were doing your when you were uh and you
know giving your last answer answer and
i was kind of flat at the end that was
because i was looking for this
and i'm sorry right now morty i haven't
been able to locate your your theory
chat but um
i think he said it like right at the
very beginning of the chat before we
even started streaming but
i'm not too sure i was just kind of
skimming through it earlier um
oh yeah i'll i'll try when i got a
second i'll try to scroll back up but um
i didn't see it on my first pass and and
i and i kind of spaced on what um
chase was saying there as a result so i
do apologize to to my guest
yeah no worries
let's see potts thank you for the 4.99
euro or pound sorry there's a theory
that kim will hand in jimmy to the
police this will get her money and
ending in a fitting way
um yeah i saw a lot of this i i i think
i saw it more from the angle of
jimmy will turn or gene will turn
himself in so that kim will get the
payday or you know he'll he'll turn him
himself into her and then she can
you know get that that five million
dollar
reward
and you know i i would say that that
seems a little bit more possible to me
like i could we're not there yet but we
could get there
but whenever you know
like if it's an idea of her betraying
him
because she wants to get paid i mean
that doesn't make any sense at all to me
because
she could have just stayed with him and
got the sandpiper money for one thing
and the other thing is i feel like a lot
of her leaving is part of it's not just
about her it's about kind of protecting
him and at the same time you know like
doing something that doing something for
him that he can't do for himself
and you know we could get into the you
know the
if that's the right way to to make
decisions or if that's a good idea or a
bad idea or all those things but
i just don't see anything in her
behavior that would point to her um
you know betraying him at this point
like she's she's she's sacrificing
herself to
you know
this thing that they have because they
she knows it's bad for them and she
doesn't think that jimmy would be able
to do it uh at least that's you know
part of my read on what's happening
there so
i don't know what do you guys think is
uh
will kim hand in jimmy to the police is
that something that you could see
happening
i like that idea better than her writing
a mode so that's that's a very um
like jimmy will set it up so he can yeah
you know turn i like that a lot but
to go back just a few minutes ago when
you're talking about um
like the the various series like jimmy
himself he was always looking for
approval back with his mom like he was
he was a favorite son because he was
funny he had his mom's approval he
wanted chuck's approval and after that
when he became saul goodman he didn't
worry about approval anymore so he just
got to do he got to live his life by
like you know
fast fast and furious um full of color
and all that stuff and being in gene's
timeline you know he's probably thinking
like a lot of us have thought in her
life where was the happiest place i ever
was in my life and he's thinking back
when i was saul goodman and i have a
feeling he's just gonna either turn
himself in or he's gonna go be saul
goodman one more time and maybe take
drastic measures whether he's gonna go
after someone whatever but he's going to
be saul goodman one more time no matter
what the expense is
so i and i think that could alone get
him arrested but if he was to set it up
and get kim the reward that'd be
fantastic
yeah yeah yeah i don't i don't know i
like the idea of gene kind of uh turning
himself in and dealing with everything
he's been hiding from i also theorized
that maybe he could give kim his
diamonds before he turned himself in
although i don't know if that she'd want
to accept that for the same reason why
she probably wants nothing to do with
the sandpiper money i mean the sandpiper
money you know it reminds her of howard
and all that and
uh i feel like she probably just wants
to live a modest life on her own i don't
really think she's looking for wealth uh
you know that's why she didn't really
care for the
mesa verde job it was making her a lot
of money it didn't fulfill her
so i i feel like she's trying to do
something that just fulfills her maybe
trying to help people in the same way
she was helping pro bono clients so
it regardless of if jimmy and kim are
actually divorced or what the deal is
with that i don't think that she
accepted any of the sandpiper money
which leads me to believe that she might
not want to accept the diamonds even
though
gene might try to give them to her uh
but i do like the idea of him eventually
turning himself in and kind of facing
you know the music
just
for the simple fact of redemption or
getting over his paranoia not wanting to
live like that anymore i'm not sure if
kim will help set that up though or if
she'll want anything to do with it she
might
figure or find out that he's in jail and
go and visit him in prison maybe that
could be their reunion i'm not too sure
but
yeah yeah i don't know that's kind of
where i stand right now i don't really
think that kim would want uh
any any of that money really i don't
really think that's what she's looking
for
yeah i i agree i agree with kiwi i i
can't imagine her being interested in in
the money it's blood money like uh like
jesse says and and breaking bad and i
just wanted to say that i have two
thoughts about with about kim and jimmy
in the future
and the first one is is um something
that stood out to me in the most recent
episode when mike and gus are talking
um in the tunnel
right after you know the cartel scene
and uh gus says you know tell me about
the lawyers and he tells them about how
they you know stood up to the police
yada yada yada but then he says
that they cannot close the file until
they have a body now that cannot close
the file is something that i've been
thinking a lot about so like of course
that means that that perhaps the file
isn't closed on howard of course so that
may come up in the future
um but also it can mean that the file on
on jimmy and kim isn't exactly closed
even though it's over for all practical
purposes as mike says so i was thinking
about their marriage right do they stay
legally married even though they're
separated because they cannot be
compelled to testify against each other
in the future so that's question number
one that i've been i've been sort of
mulling over
and question number two is i was
thinking about that teaser we got before
ahead of episode i think it was eight it
was during the hiatus when we hear kim
reciting her oath as though she's being
admitted to the bar you know the little
candle with the blood splatter on it and
so i thought um
seeing you know the episodes that
followed was that perhaps certainly in
this most recent one context to how she
was considering the oath that she took
and how she perhaps feels that she
cannot in good faith continue to be a
lawyer because she feels she's violated
her oath in some reason but something
i've been thinking of recently
uh is that perhaps she ends up getting
readmitted to the bar maybe she gets
sworn in in the future so i was thinking
um this is a little bit of fan fiction
here i don't know how practical this is
but what if kim comes back and defends
jimmy like if let's say he does turn
himself in that's a thought i've been
sort of entertaining so i'd love to hear
what you guys think about that
yeah i've been seeing a lot of comments
about that i i'm up two minds and i and
i said this in the in this other the
last stream that we did but you know for
me i agree with a lot you know a lot of
what you guys are saying about him
turning himself in
for me i i if he does that i kind of
want that to be
i kind of want it to end there
you know what i mean like i want to see
him make that decision and from that i
don't really care what happens you know
like i don't need them to to walk us
through a trial
or any of that kind of stuff like i
think it would be you know the the
resolution to the story is that he
finally
he finally uh you know
does something that
that you can get behind and say okay
well yeah this is this is you know me me
taking you know taking
responsibility for what happened or
whatever
and then you know you can decide like
what what happens to him
after that you know because it doesn't
really matter in in my mind i don't know
like there's a lot it seems like uh what
you're talking about there courtney a
lot of people have this idea that they
want to see
if he turns himself in they want to see
him
go through the court case they want to
see him in jail to see that he's you
know that actually jimmy mcgill does
pretty good in prison you know he's a
happy guy he's uh he he helps other
people out and i just think all of that
would be unnecessary to the story
i don't know what you guys think about
that
i'd like to get maybe one scene of him
just in prison you know mingling with
the other prisoners maybe doing legal
work for them or telling them what to
say
uh you know for for a defense or
something like that or good behavior i
don't really think i agree i don't
really think we need to see a court
scene
because if he whether he gets caught or
turns himself in willingly i think that
that would be good enough to leave off
there i i did originally like the idea
of kim sort of defending gene um but i
do think that kim quitting her job as a
lawyer that is a huge twist and a big
turn of events and i wouldn't really
want them to just sort of undo that in
an episode or two i i understand that
would be years in the future but
i kind of like the idea of just that
being a finite twist that kim
doesn't want to be
you know a lawyer anymore because i
always thought that she was going to
either uh you know get the sandpiper
money and actually start up her pro bono
practice or maybe she'd go to jail
herself so she'd have the sandpiper
money but she wouldn't be able to spend
it but her willingly giving up that
career is just such a huge deal for me
that i kind of want that to be cemented
to be honest i i don't want them to sort
of undo that and make that twist
uh feel feel not as impactful in that
sense
but that's just my opinion
yeah i mean i like you know i
i i guess the the big thing with the the
idea of um
that you know that you brought up the
the oath courtney like
i
i i it could go two ways i think you
know it could be a her remembering you
know why she became a lawyer or she
could become a lawyer again
i just uh
i don't i just i don't i don't want to i
don't know i just think like that i
can't really imagine
that you know that
that having the impact that it's you
know that if she she comes back to uh
specifically for for
um
you know take care of gene or whatever
do you guys think that
i mean you're kind of touching a little
bit on this chase like do you guys think
that that's still a dream she has is to
do the pro bono work or or
you know does that make sense if if she
does get the the reward or whatever that
that for her to go back to that
yeah well i i always thought you know
that was her dream because well there's
other ways to help people other than
just helping pro bono clients right like
she could go work at a soup kitchen she
could volunteer she could work in many
different
fields that could help people
she could go help a charity i mean um
and it's just a thing i feel like she
will find something else in her life
where she will be able to help those
that are in need and can't normally find
the help that they need in other ways
other than being a lawyer and i don't
really think that money
is a goal for her and uh just to just to
touch on that oath i i don't know if
we'll see it at this point anymore i
think it might be unlikely the theory
that i have but i always thought that it
was going to be a flashback to you know
kim getting sworn in and i thought that
howard was going to be there or even
chuck too because i would have liked to
see another howard or chuck flashback so
i thought that's what that was going to
be but now i'm just completely unsure
i'd still like to see that come to
fruition somehow but
i'm just not too sure anymore
all right well
craig otto thank you for the 10 what a
dream team here thank you for your
analysis would love to hear you all
discuss how nuanced that breakup scene
was
it seemed different from others on tv i
related more in ways
not the murder
i related more in ways not the murder oh
yeah okay again i was trying to figure
out what that last part meant
yeah you know the murder part is is not
the good part of that what happened out
of there but um
yeah that we i i know on
in my video i talked about this and and
we definitely talked about this a lot in
the last stream
um
you guys want to you guys want to chip
in on what you think about this
how the breakup scene was different
well it reminded me very much of um the
the argument that they have right before
she proposes to him and then they get
married so they're about to break up and
then she's like well we break up or we
get married and um it also reminded me a
little bit of the discussion that she
has with um jimmy right before lalo
shows up
when she's telling him that she quit
schweikart and coakley and he's like you
can't do this
um and
the just you can't change kim's mind
and i'm coming back around to the i love
you part like he's trying to rationalize
with her and he's like it's lalo's fault
your pro bono clients need you
i mean he's trying to persuade her and
when all of that fails that's when the i
love you comes out so it was really
really gut-wrenching and um
the line that the last line of that
conversation when kim says that she was
having too much fun
uh was a callback of course to what i
think of howard's curse on them in his
final scene when he says you know at
first i thought you guys were doing it
for the money you were doing it for fun
and i i feel like in this moment that's
kim acknowledging that
yeah like they were deluding themselves
that it was so she would have money for
the pro bono practice and she's finally
really owning up to to the fact that she
was doing it because she enjoyed doing
it and the contempt and the disgust that
she feels for herself and the delivery
of that line
is just
such a gut punch
and jimmy knows she's right you know
and uh yeah so it's just a heartbreaking
really heartbreaking hard to watch scene
yeah and i think you know when you talk
about it being nuanced it's
there's a lot of like them working
through it in real time i think is what
really sells it to me i know when you
listen to the insider podcast they you
know they were talking about some of the
the ways they set that up um
michael morris was who directed it was
talking about it and then that ray
seahorn uh interview also she was
talking about how the camera won't let
you get away and that that feeling of
just not being able to um
you know
it's like these two people are they know
that they're at the end and you know
they're they're there and neither one of
them
wants to look at the reality because kim
is actually right and what she's saying
you know
and and for jimmy you know
he knows that that once that ends once
once that ends the the conversation ends
then then so does their relationship you
know so when she walks away
i thought that was such a great uh
touch that with just the sound of the
packing tape you know because the sound
that we that we all know
and and you know it it there's no words
and he doesn't he doesn't you know get
angry he doesn't flip out he's just sort
of
just sort of stuck in that in that place
and yeah i thought it was great for all
of those reasons you know
uh eric or chase you want to add
anything
i just wanted to add that i i really
like the uh the aftermath of the hhm
scene when they're having that final
kiss down in the parking garage just the
way that kim kisses him one last time
doesn't say anything gets in the car you
knew that something was gonna happen it
was really great foreshadowing and
definitely i think after that moment
where she made that disgusting lie to
cheryl is
when she realized that she couldn't do
that anymore and she definitely had her
mind made up from then
and
i think it was a little bit dramatic
effect the way that she said in the
middle of the court because i'm not i'm
not an attorney anymore or whatever she
said you know probably could have been
more realistic ways she could have said
that but it it was just a big
you know bomb drop right there like i
was not expecting that anymore at all i
was like come on kim why aren't you
gonna do this pro bono client like come
on just get it over with and she's like
oh i'm not a lawyer anymore why what the
heck and
and then just waiting for jimmy to get
home the impending doom of the
conversation that she knows that's about
to happen and he bursts in and sees that
she's already half done packing it was
just one
one tragic twist after another and uh
the actors did an amazing job portraying
that breakup scene it i think that's
what made it feel so realistic right
just the brilliant writing the amazing
actors they just did a great job all
around and it just felt right just felt
right i hate that they had to break up
but i'm i'm glad that kim got the heck
out of dodge and you know with kim gone
it's last thing holding saul back or
jimmy back from being saul so that
jarring cut through the time jump i
think that fit perfectly as well
i i think that kiss in the parking
garage was just kim testing to see if
because i think her mind was made up the
night before when they basically come
home for the first time they sleep in
the house or the first of the apartment
for the first time after it's been
cleaned up and you know jimmy's giving
her this speech you know we'll wake up
one day we'll brush our teeth and we'll
know we'll know blah blah kim just
laying there she was completely
blank and she knew right there that um
it was definitely she had to they had to
separate i think she knew there that
they were done and maybe she wanted to
kiss him one more time just to see if
you know she could kiss him and walk
away or if you kissed him and she
couldn't be away from him and she was
able to walk away and confirm that she
can survive without them and they can
survive without each other so i i think
her mind was already made up
i think the moment was uh with cheryl i
think that was the the moment that
really cemented it for her that was the
last moment
yeah
i think what it what it was because um
re-watching it it reminded me very much
actually again
of the scene with lalo the first time he
shows up to the apartment and lalo wants
a story he wants he wants to know what
happened in the desert of course and
jimmy's telling the story and then
wallows you know he's not buying it
completely and then kim comes in and she
seals the deal right like she says what
needs to be said and i found a very
similar parallel in this scene with
cheryl so cheryl wants to know what
happened she's asking them questions
sort of giving them you know the third
degree what did you tell the police what
happened and so jimmy's telling the
story and cheryl's she's showing doubt
she's like i don't believe this and
that's when kim jumps in and she says
i don't think it's my place or maybe
it's not my place and she looks over her
shoulder and if you see there's an exit
sign so she's so uncomfortable in that
scene but she knows she has to
put this to bed right she has to to end
the doubt and right before she jumps in
uh cheryl says i'm not oblivious and
then the way kim comes in and she's like
well you would have known you were his
wife and of course jimmy and kim know
that they were separated so she knows
that's exactly the thing to say she's
telling her the subtext is you maybe you
are oblivious
and it's a devastating scene it's a
death blow really but it ended
conversation and it was exactly what it
needed to be said to to end cheryl's
doubt and i think kim knew then that you
know that was
an awful thing to do but she did it she
did it anyway and i just that was it for
her she knew it was over
yeah you know it's funny because you
know i i agree that uh
what you're saying eric is that it's up
it's up to debate on when she actually
you know
made the decision and and i i tend to
agree with courtney here and what's
funny is that when i first watched that
scene with cheryl
it you know it happened so fast and it's
just so jarring that it didn't really it
didn't really occur to me what was
happening you know i mean like i i it's
something that i had to think about for
a second like did she really do that
like you're saying it's completely
brutal like she just
she goes beyond what what what you know
immediately seems necessary but i think
when you go back and you look you think
okay well she's actually just doing what
needs to be done
and she understands that and she
realizes that this is the kind of things
that they're going to have to do
going forward and and they're good at it
you know i i mean i think if you look at
what they pulled off with howard you
know i mean it's like
it's an amazing scam
of course it ended terribly uh you know
and
even like
how jimmy said it's it's not their fault
it's lala's fault you know i mean so
it's like you could see how they could
even
sort of you know
account for things like that and say
okay well you know it was still this is
what we do it it's not our fault that
that happened and and it's just it just
keeps going and um
you know so i i kind of think you know
when i when i watched it there i thought
okay this is the straw that broke her
back you know broke the
it's where she can't go on it's the
point of no return
and by the time the kiss happened in the
parking garage like for me i was like
okay now i know that this is over and
you know she hasn't figured out how yet
maybe but you know it's gonna happen as
a result of what just went down there
and um
you know when you go back and watch it
it you can you do you kind of pick up on
the fact that she's she's kind of hating
herself the whole way the way that ray
plays it there you can see that
there's confidence enough to get past
what
um you know what what needs what she
needs to do with cheryl like she she
totally uh you know arises to the
occasion there but i feel like if you
look at the way that
she looks like she just she looks like
she's a different person and that and
that she doesn't like who it is and
when you think about the the parking
garage you know jimmy says this is the
end this is the end or what however
whatever the words that he uses actually
are there this is really the end
and it's sort of like that's the light
bulb moment
of like yeah doing that that actually is
we can't you know i can't go on anymore
with this
yeah yeah and he says it's over really
over let the healing begin and and i
mentioned this that he says that he
delivers that last part with you know
let the killing begin without any
appreciation for the sense of like what
they just did to cheryl right like they
just destroyed this woman let the
healing begin
and when i watched this live the first
time i actually thought that might be
the last time we saw kim because it went
to commercial right after that and i
turned to my husband i was like is that
it is she gone like poof because i i
don't know i just it definitely seemed
like a goodbye kiss and you know their
cars facing each other opposite
directions
it was yeah
it would have made for a great last
scene if that was just it but i mean i'm
glad they went the other route but i i
could see how you get to that and just
be like damn you know what they you know
that would have been that would have
been amazing
i
i i do like what eric was saying about
how kim was just so cold-faced in uh in
the motel room uh yeah i don't think
that that was
uh the last straw but i think that she
was definitely thinking about it and
then when everything with cheryl happens
it kind of solidified that i just i i
like the catch that courtney made in
regards to kim standing up to lalo being
similar to kim standing up to cheryl and
i wonder if kim almost had that plan
where she was hoping she wouldn't have
to say something like that but then she
did and it ended up you know kind of
being being that final straw
yeah i i i've read a lot of interviews
since you know i watched it and and
i'm not sure where i picked up on it but
at least some of the creatives behind
you know making it they they they
thought of that as as her and you know
the end for her like when it really
clicked but um
i've seen some some different ideas too
you know so
it's it's left up
you know to for us to to figure out and
i
yeah i've had so many comments about the
cheryl thing i mean it's just it's such
a
just such a perfectly written scene
because like i said in eric like how you
pointed out you know that that
she kind of carry ray seahorn kind of
carries that lost look throughout all of
these scenes from that point forward you
know what i mean
there's just so much going on and i and
i agree with what you were saying
earlier too about how it's so
rewatchable just for those things you
know so many of those things you don't
notice on the first pass and they come
up and uh it's
we're just really lucky to have this
right now i feel like you know
you know what's funny in your chat
there's a lot of people talking about
cliff maine and i don't think anyone's
ever thought about this
he he is a guy that i think we all need
to feel so sorry for
he's caught like the deer in headlights
in so many occasions like with the scam
the cocaine and and the hooker rolling
out of the car and now
at the funeral he's like uh uh uh he
just does not want to be involved in
this he admired howard i actually i
really feel sorry for him
yeah he and he and he does a great job
uh i brought this up in the live stream
i mean he he he's
he he has such uh he just he doesn't do
a lot in any of the episodes he's in but
he makes such a big impression because
we can all kind of reel up you know
we've all kind of been in that position
before where we're like in the middle of
something that we just don't want to you
know it just keeps coming and we just
want to we just want to get out because
you know we feel bad for everybody
involved
he's he's a spinal tap alum with chuck
as well too michael mccain yeah that's
true oh really
yeah he was a drummer he was one of
their many drummers that supposedly is
spontaneously blew up oh wow i didn't
know that
james eagan thanks for the a 799
wouldn't jimmy want kim to leave if he
still thinks lalo is alive how can they
justify saul saying his last name is
mcgill to walt and breaking bad
um
wouldn't jimmy want kim to leave if he
still thinks lalo is alive
i i think jim i think jimmy would want
to be with kim
if he thought that she had to leave then
they would leave together um i think is
the is where i would go on that
um
how can they justify saul saying his
last name is mcgill to walt and breaking
bad
i'm not sure
why that would be a problem
nobody really remembers him as as jimmy
mcgill in in that timeline but it's not
a secret um
he was
he's not hiding his identity he he he
chose the name saul goodman
as a
um
response to his brother dying he's doing
you know he's doing the same kind of
compartmentalization that that he does
here
when kim leaves uh there's sort of a
pattern of it if you watch like
he
i've been going back and watching scenes
for a different video i'm working on and
and when marco dies he does this the
first time he won't tell kim what's
really going on instead he
he goes into the bar and they they do
their first scam um she asked him
directly like what's what happened in
cicerone he says nothing about what
happened in cicero it's just i'm done
with this lawyer profession or whatever
and so
you know saul isn't isn't a way of
hiding who he was it's just he's he's
just going down this road that you know
it seems natural and and his real i
guess to him it seems natural for his
reaction to the things that are
happening in his life
i'm glad you really want to go because
remember you notice whenever he was
about to do something bad he'd be he'd
spin that his ring remember yeah he
always touched the ring yeah
yeah it's like his little talisman um
can i can i say something here so the
point that james that wouldn't wouldn't
he want her to leave if he thought lalo
was still alive and i think he did and
so going back to um like you know the
end of season five
when he asks if he's bad for her the way
i've read that is that he was about to
break up with her and so thinking of
their relationship in in context of what
happened with the howard scheme and i've
been reflecting on it a lot since monday
i think that perhaps um maybe what kim
was doing
in that moment when they're in the hotel
room was trying to to
cheer jimmy up and also come up with a
reason for them to stay together like if
you know going after howard would give
them something to do together because i
really think he was starting to debate
like maybe we should we should break up
i don't know if that's how everyone else
read it but like going
yeah so um
when she's in their breakup scene in the
most recent episode when she says you
know i knew what would have happened if
you know you found out and i think that
that she's referencing the fact that
they would have broken up because jimmy
would have been too scared about what
might happen with lalo so i think james
does raise an interesting question and
certainly trying to predict what would
happen here how their relationship would
end that was something that i was
considering that maybe jimmy would would
fear for her if he doubts that lalo is
really dead
yeah yeah now that you bring that up it
does make sense and and that's something
that i always wondered about and had
talked to people about in the past and i
think they made that explicit like i
think i read in a um
either a bob odenkirk or or a race
seahorn interview that
yeah part of why she even brings that
scam up with howard is because she's
trying to to bring jimmy out of his you
know
out of his ptsd basically from what
happened in the in the desert and what's
going on in his life and she she knows
that that's where they connected before
so hey this will make him feel better
and we saw that kind of
work on a certain level once he got over
his
you know his initial um not wanting to
do it in season six you know he kind of
came back a little bit before
everything went wrong again
eight hn ic8 thank you for the 4.99 the
director for episode 10 has directed the
most breaking bad episodes in some of
the most intense violent
breaking bad scenes
foreshadow for bcs episode 10. thank you
kiwi and courtney yeah michelle mclaren
um
she's done a couple of better calls all
but she she was a lot more involved in
breaking bad and and just more active i
think in general
uh you know she she's
she's done episodes of a ton of shows
that um
great shows and great episodes so it is
exciting to see her come back here
i i don't know um
i got the impression i don't know if you
guys had this also but i got the
impression that this might be a funny
episode um
i i know that peter gold at one point
said that they have one that that's
really unexpectedly funny and
it seems like that might fit in here
especially with walt and jesse coming
back um
i'm not sure
the
i i don't i don't anticipate a lot of
violence in the breaking bad time the
time we spend in breaking bad but i
don't know i'll throw it out to you guys
what do you guys think
they were stumped i don't know i don't
know yeah i don't know either so
yeah
go ahead go ahead i was just gonna say
the title of course everyone's
questioning what the title could
possibly mean nippy right so i was
thinking obviously whether right so
maybe it's in a cold environment so
maybe we're back in nebraska i was also
thinking about a line that kim's mom
says in the flashback when they're in
the department store she says it twice
actually um nip it in the bud right so
maybe nippy could be like kim's mom or a
reference to kim nipping her bad
behavior in the bud something like that
um
i don't i have no idea what to expect
with episode 10. i have no clue
i mean just the
really quick
i mean i i from what i understand walt
and jesse are absolutely showing up in
this episode is that that's correct
right that's been um
i believe
yeah but i mean i think that i think
that they've actually
confirmed that right
yeah i think there was a there was a
deadline article where i think aaron
paul confirmed that jesse would be in
the next episode
yeah that's what i'm talking about i
couldn't remember exactly so thank you
for those details
so yeah i mean i think that
we can talk about that too uh in a bit
but i mean
i think it's gonna i think it's gonna
i don't know i can't really see that
being violent you know like i don't
really uh it's not coming to my head
right right at the moment like i i and i
but i could see it being like
you know give us a different take on on
his the way that he you know he he got
to know them or
sort of
underestimated them
and then how that you know kind of has
an effect on
his his state of mind whenever he's in
the gene timeline
well what i'm interested in is are we
going to get some sort of story arc that
either lasts one episode or two episodes
that goes alongside breaking bad but we
see it from saul's perspective or is it
gonna be a bunch of strung along missing
scenes kind of like all the missing
scene flashbacks from el camino because
i originally thought that the walton
jesse uh cameos were just gonna be sort
of like a cold open uh kind of like
episode 405 quite a ride but now it
seems like we're gonna have a full
episode or two in the breaking bad
timeline and in regards to bob odenkirk
mentioning you know that carol burnett
was gonna play a major role in some sort
of story arc here i'm wondering if
they're going to do some sort of
full-blown arc that lasts a full episode
or two in the timeline
i just think that'd be really
interesting for them to try and come up
with something original
to go alongside the events of breaking
bad while also weaving through them at
the same time
yeah i mean it could be interesting one
of the things that i think about is you
know when you're doing a prequel
you can you can pretty much presume that
everybody's seen the original series
it's one of the most popular tv series
of all time
but then you know in in the future
do you really want to
to show a lot of stuff that happens in
in the original
in the prequel you know what i mean like
it's kind of an interesting situation
there of like
when you when you watch the breaking bad
for the first time
you don't really want to know too much
about
you know those characters
like does that make sense it does yeah
because you've already seen it you've
already seen it and we and we've watched
it a hundred times over uh so we know
what's happening with walt and jesse
stuff like that but i do like the
thought of seeing it possibly
they could be they could be very little
in in this but important and seeing it
through saul's eyes from his his
perspective
that'd be pretty cool and we we do know
that they don't do things just for fan
service so it's not just going to be oh
look there they are at a red light you
know like it's going to be it's going to
be something i would i just don't know
what it is yet but
yeah i agree i think like when we see
walt and jesse it has to further the
better call saul story line somehow it
has to tell us something more
about the characters so i was trying to
think of like when in the timeline it
would make the most sense um i know a
lot of people think like it might pick
up right like where they first meet him
but i don't think that's necessary and
why show us something we've already seen
so i was thinking maybe something like
um
maybe when um
[Music]
right when they're decide like when walt
and jesse are planning on on killing
gus and perhaps when um they're in like
the laser tag and you see you see um
mike go into saul's office and he
threatens to break his legs i think that
would be an interesting moment to see
from saul's point of view and also maybe
gives a little bit more context to their
relationship perhaps i don't know
something like that i'm not saying it's
going to be that but something that
furthers the storyline in some way
and two they can they can try some
things that they did like they maybe
thought i wish we could have did this in
the breaking bad environment now they
can actually finish some things maybe
that they wanted to finish and they've
moved away from
yeah
i was looking at this uh
interview where he said uh you know they
were coming back and he said i think the
way he said but the way i think the way
you see them and when you see them won't
necessarily be what you'd expect
so i mean i've always kind of thought
that they would be in the breaking bad
timeline because it just didn't make as
much sense story-wise for them to be in
the bcs sign so i don't know if he's
referring to that there
but you know he also said that i think
the way that they do appear is all about
the story of jimmy mcgill and kim wexler
and mike erman trout
which you know that that that makes you
think oh well maybe they'll he'll
actually be with those characters but i
think what he's saying there is more of
like it'll be about this you know the
the better call saul story not about
uh you know adding details to breaking
bad or putting a finer point on things
from the better you know breaking bad
perspective
yeah yeah well with the uh with the
peter gould interview we know that the
walton jesse cameo it'll have something
to do with the
jimmy kim and mike relationship because
that's what peter was saying in that
interview so made a whole video about
this but long story short i wonder if
jimmy and mike will just mention kim in
front of walt and jesse or if walt and
jesse will actually meet them briefly at
some point
and um
to add to what courtney was saying i
would like to see more mike versus saul
some sort of altercation there um i
would really like to see more of these
uh sort of missing scene type of
situations like from el camino where we
saw
jesse talking to mike which was in
between uh one of the episodes after uh
jesse leaves walt he's whistling happy
happily while jesse's you know sat over
uh
that uh that kid on the dirt bike dying
and then aft and then the missing scene
happens and then mike and jesse go and
tell walt that they're out of the game
or the uh missing scene with the rv
after they get out from being trapped in
the desert so something like that would
be really nice i'd like to see maybe
more behind the scenes with walt telling
saul he wants to steal the ryzen
cigarette um one of my favorite walt
theories is having a missing scene
during the time that walt and saul are
hiding in ed's vacuum store while
waiting to be relocated uh during one of
the final few episodes so a lot of
missing scenes that they could do that i
think would be really good i'd also like
to see more of saul's class action
lawsuit on wayfair 515 maybe potentially
have saul speak to walt about it since
walt is somewhat guilty for it but
refuses to admit it i think that could
be interesting i think it would be
something more than just oh mr mayhew
walks in in the door and curtain call or
or we see walt at the car wash and
curtain call you know ass has to have
some sort of significance towards that
but i'm just really interested in how
the walton jesse cameo could aid the
mike jimmy
and kim relationship especially if kim's
not
in the picture and breaking bad that
just really threw me for a loop when
peter gould said that so i'm really
interested to see
what exactly will happen there
yeah i mean the way i i interpreted that
was that
you know
story he's saying the story of those
three which is better called saul you
know what i mean so
how it affect how his relationship to
walter white affects him you know that
has an effect on
on kim also you know just because
that he she's a part of his life as well
it could be more literal but i i don't
know i think he's trying to be trying to
be a little bit cute there
yeah i could be taking it a little bit
too literally like you know maybe maybe
walt and jesse don't actually meet kim
but i would like to hear miker or jimmy
bring it up in passing while in front of
them i think that'd be really
interesting for
walt and jesse to at least heard of kim
at some point not not enough to you know
be significant because we have to work
within the confines of breaking bad but
i still think that that would be an
interesting take
absolutely
david rogers thank you for the ten
dollars the happy ending jimmy coming
clean and going to prison where he helps
fellow inmates with their legal problems
yeah we were talking about this just a
minute ago and um
i don't know if there's anything else to
add i just you know my my thought on it
is i don't need to see that happen i
mean the fact that we all we all are
in agreement that that might happen is
enough for me but um you know we could
see they might go there
drew shape thank you for the five euros
last two to three episodes were great
but chicanery is still the best in my
opinion would love to see chuck come
back for a flashback do you think it's
possible
i sure hope so
i don't think so
yeah it's one of those things you know
like i i i would love to see it i don't
necessarily think it's in the cards
though
yeah
i really wish though
i could see them doing it so like you
know how at the end of breaking bad like
they have the flashback to like jessie
and walt when they first cook and
you know um walt with skyler and the
happier day so i could i could see like
perhaps they do a flashback for jimmy
remembering
things from earlier on in the series i
could see that maybe like yeah yeah you
get me out of jail slipping jimmy out of
jail back in the day
exactly
yeah i absolutely think it would make
sense um you know i i just the the one
thing that kind of makes me
um
think that they're they're not is
michael mckean uh you know he was he
kind of made that statement about
if you keep bringing him back then it
loses you know some of its
some of its weight or whatever i can't
remember how he said it but
um you know he he didn't think that they
would be doing it too many flashbacks
but of course it would it would make
sense i mean he was such a big part of
the series and it's we're almost you
know
at the point at the end of season six
we're almost you know we almost had as
many episodes without him as we had with
him at this point so
you know it would be great to to
and he's a great actor so anytime you
can get him involved like let's do that
bertilan gardos
huff 400 uh thank you for that
that's going to be
the latest episode that's going to be
the latest episode um
okay
i was doing autocorrect in my in my
reading there
yeah this is
that's going to be what is um i'm a
little bit do you guys have any
interpretation of this maybe maybe they
mean like episode 10 coming up maybe
that's the latest episode i think maybe
yeah i don't know how to respond to it
i'm
trying to get some context from what's
going on in the chat at that time but i
i i'm not coming up i'm sorry
bertallon
i do appreciate the super chat but i
don't
i don't know how to answer it
yeah i'm at a loss
stringfellow hawk thank you for the five
there's a lot to talk about gene saul
returning to turn himself in was he ever
known to be working for walt by law
enforcement i've forgotten
um it's heavily implied if you watch the
american greed
segment they made
it's absolutely explicit in that um
but yeah there there's this teaser that
they put out before the season where
there's a uh wanted poster
and uh i'm kind of thinking that that's
showing us the end of the series and and
we just sort of it was just so shocking
that they put that out before the season
that we
we kind of all collectively just sort of
do a little bit of compartmentalizing
ourselves and be like well that can't
actually happen if they showed it to us
right but
i do believe
they never made it explicit inside any
episode or during the run of the show
but
he
i believe he's a known associate and
they want him because they know he's
alive and
he's facing all sorts of uh
jail time if they do get their hands on
him
yeah i i mean saul's associated with
walt right and i've i've honestly gotten
so many comments of people being like
why is saul even on the run is gene why
is he like
i don't know i don't know i've just
gotten a lot of comments questioning
that and in regards to the american
greed and the the saul bounty promo
whether it's canon or not i'm not sure
if they they've confirmed it or not i
choose to believe that they're both
canon but that's just me
um i'm not sure if you guys believe that
it's canon or not because sometimes they
do promos that are just promos but i
mean even with el camino promo with
skinny pete you know getting arrested
and being interrogated i still choose to
believe that that's canon as well even
though it's not an actual
but again that's just me
yeah i agree that it's definitely canon
and also just one one more thought about
why jimmy would be wanted or saul would
be wanted is um i think probably like
all of the sort of legal services that
he was providing for waltz i mean he
never actually goes to court or i think
like actually does any paperwork or
anything like that so everything was off
the books you know you see that that
walt pays him in rolls of cash so
certainly the irs is going to be
interested and um of course the checks
made out to ice station zebra associates
the loan out so there's some some big
questions that remain about that
and uh is that above board or how how is
that business working so i think that
probably is in large part why he is
wanted
that's basically how they use rico laws
and you know he he would fall under all
kinds of
conspiracy and
organize crime in a way wouldn't he
wouldn't it be funny if the kettleman's
tournament for tax evasion
yeah liberty
i don't know if it was your idea
initially or not but courtney you
brought the idea of um
the kettleman's being behind ice station
zebra and uh i think there's some
definite possibility of that
yeah well i was thinking about the um
sorry chase but the american greed thing
right and like how they're interviewed
of all the potential clients why those
two so maybe they make some sort of plea
with the d.a and they they spill
everything that they know and they they
claim that they were you know forced to
to do this by jimmy against their their
will sort of thing so i was just kind of
imagining that as a scenario that they
are the ice station zebra associates
did you uh did you mention that in one
of your videos or is that a theory that
you've been floating around for a while
or
yeah i mentioned i don't know if we
actually talked about it live pete i
know we've spoken about it um before and
it's it's i don't know if i have
actually mentioned it in a video or not
i think i did pretty sure i did like a
theory and prediction video a while back
okay because yeah all i was gonna say is
that i've gotten like a comment or two
saying that but it was really recent so
that'd be funny if it kind of came
through the grapevine from one of your
videos or something like that
it would it would explain the the
inflatable liberty on top of this
building
yeah someone said that yeah i saw that
all right the recovery 716 thank you for
the 9.99 all my favorite channels in one
place
break it's breakups in general suck i
thought kim was gonna break up with him
in
wechsler v goodman you guys think the
cab driver has something to do with kim
i do not um oh god
yeah i i don't think
he has anything to do with kim um
trying to think of how to to just
say this succinctly
i understand
that that
and chase and i have talked about this
before i think we actually cut it from
the last video that we made though i
don't think that that
conversation ever went out there but um
yeah yeah i i
i understand that there's this this uh
you know this the the air freshener it's
kind of a weird thing
and um i get the idea that they're
trying to there there's a there's a way
to connect those two dots but i just it
doesn't make any sense to me because of
the way that
they first came in contact jeff picks
him up at the at the hospital
it seems pretty random i don't see how
you could you could manufacture that
meeting so that kind of undermines any
of like
jeff is working for somebody theories
for me
yeah yeah you guys can tip in
i i think that i i do agree that i think
that jeff picking up gene from the
hospital was coincidental and if they
try to
make it seem like it was intentional
that would be a tricky retcon to do
because i don't think that was their
original intention now the potential
jeff the cab driver recasting i guess
anything's possible but i just don't
think that's the case and also
um
don't think jeff would have been so
maniacal about i think he would have
been more straightforward hey kim hired
me to come find you you gotta come with
me i don't think he'd just oh you'll do
better next time
seems like such a weasel seems like he
has his own agenda i don't think he'd be
so mysterious if it was just kim uh but
yeah he's he's threatening him right i
mean isn't that the interpretation is
like he's he's not like
you know like i'm going to do something
but he's letting him know that he could
do something right
yeah yeah it's that subtle implication
of you'll do better next time well what
does he mean by that
do better next time when
he clearly isn't an undercover cop he
didn't just you know he would have just
arrested him right then and there
um but wait what does he have planned
for him that's the whole thing that uh i
guess gene wants to put a stop to before
he finds out
but yeah we we definitely circled the
drain with that with that topic a lot
trying to think this i do like the
initial theory i do like the initial
idea that maybe jeff has something to do
with kim because the isotope air
freshener but that's just because of the
fact that i wanted
that isotope air freshener that kim
holds up to have some greater
significance because they knew that we
see that the first thing we're going to
think of is jeff but it could have just
been as simple as showing that that's a
very common object in albuquerque and
that's about it misdirection
yeah maybe you think your fresheners are
sold at a1a car wash
yeah there you go
e-covenant kid thank you for the five
dollars well i think it's unlikely
seeing jimmy reflect on his wedding
photos he'll took would be very
bittersweet
yeah absolutely i was looking at that
scene yesterday and uh
it's such a great it's such a great
little wedding they have there um
if i was jimmy if i was jimmy and i
looked at those that would actually you
know would crush me so i agree with you
100
um the recovery
716.
thank you for the 199 again this is a
direct kiwi question what when's your
season four tier list dropping
i'll give you a quick update on that i
just finished uh the scripting for all
10 episodes i just gotta record and edit
it so that's that's where i'm at with
for that right now
cool the judo joker thank you for the
10. my prediction will get a saul only
episode and a kim only episode in the
kim only episode my theory is
it would start with flashback of kim
helping her mom cover up a fatal hit and
run
that's a twist that i have not thought
of that her mom might need her for
something like that
um
yeah so a couple of things this brings
up a couple of things that that we
wanted to hit on
one of the things is hey like
the one of the things that i thought
about after the fact is that
episode nine actually feels like a
series finale and i don't know
we'll i'll let you guys all one by one
kind of uh weigh in on that but you know
if if it is a if if it was intended that
way if they did want to tie up all of
the story threads that were
were happening in the bcs timeline um
which they pretty much did you know they
they capped off
uh gus's story really well
they you know kind of gave mike that
moment with uh
manuel varga that really put a nice you
know put put a nice uh
stopping point for his story through bcs
you know just sort of a conclusion
if that's the case you know they really
can do anything in this next next four
episodes and
one of the things they could do is they
could do a complete
kim story because you know i've talked
about this you know this this
this this idea of addiction and about
abstinence you know if she's choosing
abstinence and and she's leaving him so
that makes it really kind of tricky if
they were going to
come back together so so the question is
like do we have another kim ark you know
i mean is that is that something that's
going to happen because
we kind of have to see how she you know
how she gets to wherever she's at
you know she can't i i don't think she
can be a complete mystery i guess what
i'm saying is i don't think she can be a
complete mystery of like what she's been
up to and what what what what's happened
to her over all those years
it's like six years right um
and just have her show back up in the
gene timeline so could we get a whole
full
kim episode or a lot of kim you know
gene
genish kind of scenes
mixed in there with whatever's going on
so yeah i i i like this question thank
you judo joker
i like the idea of of that hit fatal hit
and run although i don't know there's
any evidence that that something like
that would happen
so uh yeah we'll just go down the line
and it's a lot to to
bring up but um eric you can go first if
you want um touch on those i don't think
we'll get a full cam episode and as much
as we're hoping for a full gene episode
i'm not sure if we'll get that because
there's not a lot of episodes left and
they really there's still a story to
tell
um
but i think we're going to see a lot
more of kim i think we're going to see
more of kim where she is where she's
decided to go to i don't that's not the
last we're going to see of her um
but i don't think we're going to see a
full episode of this and as you talked
about if that was the last ending let's
just say there's some force of nature
that made that the last episode um for
whatever reason i could have lived with
that but i'm glad it didn't like i mean
it was great i could be okay that was
pretty darn good ending um no one you
know uh not like breaking bad from
walter dies um
i'm just glad that we do have some more
it's like we're we're graced by what
five more or three more episodes i
forgot what count we're at for a second
but yeah we're it's a little bit of
bonus content for us now but um
yeah yeah and i think that they've
implied that that you know that they can
that they're gonna take some take some
big swings and do some different things
that we can't you know we couldn't have
seen coming and and that's pretty
exciting you know and and i like that
that they kind of did such a good job
like you said eric of just like that
could have been the series finale
i would have been totally happy with
that um
it would have been haunting me you know
like what comes next and they kind of
they kind of can't do that because they
did introduce gene you know but as far
as like wrapping up that story i thought
they did a fantastic job
what do you think courtney
yeah so we chat a little bit about this
before we started but this did feel like
a a conclusion to the better call saul
storyline right so we everything is
wrapped up we get to see what happens
with gus we get to see what happens with
mike and in my opinion it's kind of like
the last step in the transformation to
the characters that they are in breaking
bad
so um i would love to see more kim and i
think we will definitely see more kim um
like eric i'm not sure that we'll get a
full kim episode i would love that i
would love to see more of her i was
thinking a little bit about um the end
of season one the beginning of season
two so we have marco and then switch and
when jimmy decides to quit the law so
it's before he gets you know suspended
um he goes back to cicero and i was
wondering if we would see something um a
parallel to to kim where does kim go at
this point does she stay in albuquerque
i mean she packed up all her stuff i
think she's probably getting out of town
does that mean going back to red cloud
for some reason to face some old ghosts
there um or does she go elsewhere i
think uh we certainly haven't seen the
end of kim's story i don't know if we'll
get it in the next episode i don't know
if they'll do that maybe they'll
um wait a while to show us what's going
on with her but i think i think we're
definitely going to see her in as far as
the series goes i think there's really
only one major question left to answer
and that is um really what happens with
with gene and does um just does jimmy
sullivan have to
face up to who he is and what he he does
or what he did
um so i think that's every and i say
that's as sort of to preface that i
think everything that happens from here
on out has to serve that
question or that that one plot point of
what's going to actually happen to him
what is what does he deserve what's
going to happen
yeah
and i'm i want to uh there's a couple
things you said that i that i wanted to
touch on because um
we're hitting the one we're hitting the
90-minute mark here and um i'm not sure
how long you guys can stay i'm gonna
don't worry i'm gonna answer all of the
super chat i know there's a lot of them
waiting there so don't worry i'm gonna
go through all those but i'm not sure
if everyone else is gonna be able to
stay for how long and all of that so um
you brought up the idea of uh
you know the
what it what what how it needs to serve
that and like in your in your opinion
you know what what does the show need to
do in the last four i mean i'm asking
you this specifically because i i know
that i know what you studied at school
and all of that so what do you think
that what do you think the show has to
do
like if this was a if this was a story
you know like if you're thinking about
it story-wise like where where does what
what is the responsibility of of of a
story when it gets to this point
well i think um and this is something a
point that i made in in the video that i
just put up my my breakdown of this
episode i think um we see all the
characters reckoning with who they
really are right so like
they go face to face with other
characters and in that moment they see
themselves reflected back to them so you
have that moment with um with gus and
the cartel and the hatred in his eyes
and there's such a such a great shot of
the fire in his glasses and the line
that um don elario says about like how
he saw a little bit of the hate in his
eyes and then you see him in this next
scene in a much lighter brighter moment
where he's
he's i think the hap only genuinely
happy
moment that we have ever seen with gus
and he you know the taste of the bloody
wine he remembers sangre por sangre and
he comes to terms with who he is and
what he really wants and he's bent on
revenge right and i think that's the
moment where he puts aside any any
any other thoughts about what his life
could be
and decides that this is this is the
trajectory for him and i think with mike
the moment when he comes to face to face
with manuel varga
is the same thing he has this idea of
himself and i think when he's describing
nacho as this guy with a good heart who
just got caught up with the wrong people
i think um
that's talking about himself
right that's how he wants to view
himself and then uh even though mike
doesn't speak spanish or probably
understand spanish i think he can
certainly you know infer what the tone
means right like the sort of disdain
that that he says you know like you're
all the same um and that's not justice
that's revenge and i think he's holding
up a mirror to mike and mike is really
taking a hard look at himself
and um this he's accepting that this is
who and what he is and so just another
point about mike that we were talking
about pete is um this this idea of
sobriety and addiction and we see mike
holding a beer in this episode as he's
sitting on you know on his chair
watching the game right before he goes
i have a blue ribbon
exactly yeah so he's kind of
um i think
surrendered a little bit to to the the i
don't i guess the darker impulses or
that this is just who and what he is
um
yeah and so for i think and i think with
kim of course that reckoning comes when
she comes face to face with cheryl so i
think she and she's the one that steps
away she's like this is not what i want
and she's the one that you know goes
cold turkey if you wanted to follow
through with the sort of addiction
metaphors there but i think to answer
your question since we that's what we've
been shown already with all the other
characters that is what's missing with
jimmy
and instead of facing up to who or what
he is he goes into like saw mode right
and the fact that show him from the
moment his eyes open in the morning that
he's go go go go go toro negocios it's
all business right that is how he is he
is coping by just distracting himself
and throwing himself into this persona
and this act so i think he definitely
needs to come to terms with who he is
what he's done
and um
i hope there's there's some hope for
redemption for him uh
maybe he comes back and tries to set
things right in some way that's what i
what i'm hoping will happen that's what
i think probably will happen but we'll
see i don't see him getting away with it
no it wouldn't be fitting you know there
there needs to be resolution to like to
to him
at least if not not one for one you know
like he he has to he has to get to that
same place that the the other characters
the way that you just laid out so so
perfectly there
and and i have i i was just thinking
when you were talking maybe eric or
um
kiwi might know the answer to this uh
it's been a while since i rewatched
breaking bad in its entirety but how
long was was walt in
in exile
but do you guys know either one of you
offhand i don't i don't
he went with ed and he he was there for
some
for a period of time right he he hid out
in what was in new hampshire
at least six months for sure maybe the
better part of a year
that's what that's what my that's what
my guess would have been
yeah so so like i was just thinking
about that a little bit in in in
relationship to to gene you know like
how long his exile's been it has to be
longer than that right you know i mean
because they both disappeared at the
same time
yeah true that's right that's what you
compare
yeah so he he you know he he's been
living with himself without the the
filter for for for a while by the time
that we see jeff come into his life so
yeah i agree with what you're saying
there courtney that
he you know that that that should be
enough time for him to to put it
together and just say like i have to i
have to reckon with this because um
that's just kind of how you know stories
work right you know that's how you kind
of get to a conclusion so yeah chase i
didn't mean to cut you out of that you
can you can uh chime in on all those
different things too if you want to
yeah for sure so i actually just looked
up on the uh breaking bad fandom and it
says granite state happens from march
15th to september 4th so six months
uh so i guess he was up up there for up
there for six months um
in in regards to the whole uh kim or
jimmy episode i don't think they're
gonna do
an entire bottle episode i mean
the walking dead kind of put a bitter
taste in my mouth in regards to bottle
episode shout out season seven i i like
i like the walking dead season seven
more than most people honestly and and
they've done some really good episodes
like here's not here the the morgan monk
backstory from season five or six i
believe it's one of my favorite episodes
uh so my point being is that sometimes a
bottle episode can can be a little bit
underwhelming because you're even though
you tell a really good story with just
one or two characters you can get stuck
there and if you have too many bottle
episodes in a row especially it takes
too many episodes to get back to what
the viewers really want to see so if we
did see me a mainly kim episode because
i would like to see what she's doing
during breaking bad you know maybe catch
up with her and her mom or even if it's
just a really tiny scene with her mom
you know even if her mom's not carol
burnett is some other actor i would
still like to see a little bit of that
um if we do get a kim heavy episode it
would still be nice to jump back and
forth between maybe one or two other uh
characters or timelines or something
like that i don't think that we're good
i mean technically we could get a sol
bottle episode with him during his
breaking bad shenanigans but i i don't
think it's going to be uh too much of a
quote-unquote bottle episode i think we
will jump back because even even in
season one with uh mike's uh episode 5-0
it wasn't technically a full-on mic
bottle episode because we did see
jimmy get involved with uh helping him
in the current timeline with the
detective so even though it was a mike
you know heavy episode we still saw a
little bit you know of jimmy and and
whatnot i think that's like the only
episode that kim wasn't in uh so
it'd be it's gonna be kind of weird not
seeing kim for a few episodes if that's
the case i do think that she has to play
a major role in the series finale but
yeah can i can i ask you just so i can
respond to what you're saying like how
are you defining bottle episode are you
like when i think of the word bottle
episode i think about like
uh a really focused location that they
use to say like this applies a little
bit more to like old network tv shows
like where they would they would cut
budget on one thing by having everything
happen in one one room or one location
and so they would call that a bottle
episode because of that but it would
have the it would have the it would have
the other
uh you know it would have the other
effect of like really focusing in on one
aspect of a character or something like
that so you're talking more about about
that i guess when you're saying um when
you're using the definition right
yeah yeah i mean i i guess people have
different definitions of bottle episodes
i know that was a debate within uh
within the walking dead uh because we
were calling season seven bottle
episodes and people well technically
it's not but i'd say like for example
um an episode that's only kim we don't
see anyone else from the main cast just
kim and maybe a surrounding few
characters around her doesn't
necessarily have to only be in one
location but it could be
um
like in the walking dead there was a
maggie and sasha episode that was just
at the hilltop and then we have a daryl
and negan episode that's just at the
sanctuary and then we have a carol and
morgan episode that's just at the
kingdom and so i guess kind of you know
just one character focus just one
isolated story with one or two
characters for the entire duration of
the episode essentially
yeah because one of the one one of the
things that because i had a comment
about that that kind of made me think
about that and like
you know someone said that they could
give kim her her 5-0 you know like
in relation to mike's um you know season
one episode like sort of his origin
story into that timeline
and i thought that made sense in that
context like i you know i wasn't
thinking about it as as taking away from
the other thing i just i was thinking
about it more but like helping to make
sense
what happens at the very end you know
because like like i was saying like she
she's not at a place whenever she's
she's um wrapping up those boxes to
to come back into jimmy's life you know
she's making a conscious decision to
leave it because like all the things
that we've said so far like it actually
makes sense is it we don't want to see
it happen but it is actually
kind of the responsible thing to do
i guess i guess the only technical
bottle episode that breaking bad or
better call saul has ever done would be
the fly episode right because yeah that
that's a classic that's a classic
example of what the way people use it
sort of like
as a as a pejorative like you know that
it's a bad thing when shows do it
because they're they're trying to to
save budget and you know
they they tell this story that goes
nowhere for
just the sake of of you know moving
things along at a different pace or
whatever
it can be really polarizing for sure
right because a lot of people absolutely
hate the fly episode a lot of people
absolutely love the fly episode
sometimes bottle episodes can be really
good for character building and
backstory and just a really in-depth
focus on on a particular character or
two but you know we only have four
episodes left i don't really think we
have time for that so if we did have a
kim heavy story or a sol heavy story i
think it would still kind of be like
mike's 5-0 where it was you know mostly
mike but then we still saw a little bit
of jimmy here and there so even if it
was a kim heavy episode i think we would
see a little bit of other characters you
know kind of floating around whether
cutting to and from whether they're
involved with kim or not i still think
that we would see a little bit of
something else as well it wouldn't just
be a hundred percent only kim central
yeah and i didn't mean to
i didn't really mean to be like you know
they have to to to push everything else
out just so we can focus on cam i think
one of the things they do really
a great job of is setting up these
things that mirror other things from
this different characters and
you know
that would certainly be fine to throw
that i was thinking about that earlier
whenever you think about episode three
you know the only thing that really the
big thing that happens is it's it's
nachos end but even in something like
that they still manage to throw in some
some really interesting stuff that's
going on
you know outside of that like with the
the you know uh yeah
the d.a and and and her investigation
and um you know what's going on with
different
do you want us outside cartel or do you
want to be a rat
yeah you know that does happen in the
exact same episode
yeah
yeah all right so
go down that rabbit hole too hard
courtney or eric do you guys want to add
anything there because i'm gonna jump
back into the questions if not no i'm
okay myself yeah go ahead
all right
commodus thank you for the five why does
kim say you would pull the plug on the
scam and then and then we would break up
she's only staying with him because the
scams they do
yeah this is interesting this is
something we could talk about um
you know my my interpretation
is that
not not that it's the only reason
they're together but
it is a reason they could break up does
that make sense like it's a it's a it's
a big part of of what keeps them
together
but it's also you know it's also a thing
that they could break up about if you
try to put on the brakes
i don't know i i found like when kim was
listening off all the reasons why she
didn't tell jimmy about lalo i didn't
really find
maybe i got to rewatch that scene maybe
there isn't and then we would but i
didn't really think of those two things
as being related i thought that
her
um
not telling jimmy because she wanted to
go along with the schemes i thought that
that was separate then maybe them
breaking up like like
one thing is that oh you would want to
run away and
go and hide in a hotel to make sure
we're safe so we wouldn't do the schemes
and i wanted to do that but
yeah i'm not i'm not quite sure how
not doing the schemes would lead to them
breaking up because well i'm i mean
doing the schemes is kind of what
brought them together right because the
first time we ever see them kiss is
after they do that scheme and the
or the con in in the season two premiere
and every single time that they do con i
believe in uh
what was it uh season three or season
four
i
think it was season four um kim gets mad
at jimmy because of the whole heal
situation when he assaulted that uh
off-duty cop or whatever and kim got mad
that
uh saul or jimmy didn't tell her that he
was selling burner phones on the side
but then they do that whole coshatta con
and
then they pretty much make up because
the con
sparks their relationships so i guess
maybe kim thinks that if we're not
conning we're not going to be happy
together but i i do think that there is
some alternate universe where jimmy and
kim could still be together without
conning
yeah it's super complicated and i'm
gonna let you guys i don't i'm not
trying to cut you off um
uh eric and courtney uh
they're
it's super complicated and it's funny
because i keep getting questions
and i'm reading them and and they're
really solid questions if you only focus
on one part of what happens there you
know what i mean like it's almost
impossible to do because
it's happening it's developing in real
time and you know you kind of alluded to
this earlier uh courtney um you know the
the fact that like
part of what they're doing here part of
the reason
part of a major part of the reason why
they ended up where they did and how
howard ended up dead was because
she brought this
into their relationship because she
thought it would help jimmy recover from
what was going on at with the ptsd so
uh yeah i mean i just wanted to to throw
that in there like it's really hard to
to just pull out one of the things that
they say here and be like why did that
happen or or what is the the meaning of
it you know so
her saying that they would break up
you know what was what was your take on
it eric
i don't know
this question here yeah i i don't i
don't know like
it's i was thinking about this driving
the car today like it's kim kim will do
bad when it's good for kim
and she's gonna be really invested in
this scam i think more obviously in the
initial onset more than jimmy was she
really wanted to get howard back
um and it bothers me sometimes that it's
the bad things that she'll do um like
she gets mad at jimmy when he does
something wrong right a question outside
what type of lawyer are you going to be
those questions she's asking before you
can play by the book that's okay for her
to not play by the book when it's good
for her
so
i'm i'm not 100 sure i i just don't know
but um
i'm i'm still i'm still baffled on i
don't know i don't know the right answer
to that
okay courtney yeah it's very complicated
and and chase mentioned the kushata
episode and that's one that i think
where it's it's a major turning point
for kim because that's when they go to
lubbock texas
and or right after right after kusha and
that's when they pulled a little like
the leaky breast milk on the the plan so
she can get a bigger lot for mesa verde
and um they're having that conversation
in the diner afterwards and uh
she says you know i think we should only
use our powers for good and he points
out how did what we just
do how was that good right like it only
benefited mesa faraday and as i
mentioned earlier pete you were alluding
to this
i think um the whole howard scheme was
really born out of uh she was trying to
save the relationship because i think
jimmy was on the verge of breaking up
with her because of the threat of lalo
and this was her way of saying like look
this is something we do together that
that's that's fine we can bond over this
and it's couched in this this
false narrative of course that it's just
to get the money for the um
for the pro bono practice and how
they'll do good with it so they're
they're so they're they're rationalizing
and you know lying to themselves about
what what it's all about so i think that
line specifically we would have broken
up was because it was sort of a long
time coming and it would they would have
broken up
back at the end of season five if they
didn't have this scheme
mm-hmm that's the way i i read it
yeah
and that's and that's like you were
saying that that's where it gets
complicated because she's saying that
because
she's trying to protect
jimmy you know what i mean like and i
think this is where you know that idea
of having another kim episode really is
is uh you know uh interesting to me is
like
i'm not really sure what what really
stands out to me as the mystery of this
scene at the end is like i'm not sure
if she's going into exile to to sort of
punish herself you know sort of take on
all the responsibility of this you know
he
and and because that's dark you know i
mean like i don't really want to accept
that that's what's happening like but
you know it's also kind of hard to say
hey she's doing this because it's the
healthy move and she's going to go off
and
and just live a different life and and
everyone's going to be better off for it
i mean we know how that ends up for
jimmy and his transformation to seoul
and you have to imagine that she has
something like that ahead of her too you
know what i mean like there's a lot of
people throwing out the idea like oh
they're going to come together at the
end and you're going to realize that
she has a different life and she's she's
married and has children or something
like that and it's like i don't really
see how you get where you know get from
her
taping up those boxes to thinking like
she just moves on clean you know what i
mean like it doesn't seem natural like a
natural progression for the character
for me
yeah agreed i definitely think she's
punishing herself and um i think um
that scene with her mom again in the
department store i think she was in some
weird way like she wanted her mom's
attention and that's what she was doing
and then you know she gets reprimanded
and her mom is like she's gonna wish
we'd call the police and you know
blah blah blah blah and they they walk
out and kim holds her mom's hand and
then when her mom starts making fun of
the store manager though and mocking him
and how easy it was to do them that's
when she lets go of her hand and i think
for kim like that was a problem right
like she wanted consequences but then of
course we see the earrings and she wears
the earrings so you have this like
reality to kim she's very conflicted
and i think um
again like that scene at the end of um
point and shoot when she's sitting on
the bed
that the picture you have up right here
is sort of a call back to that scene and
it was going to be a problem for her
that there were no consequences that
she's getting away with it again sort of
thing
and i think with her way of imposing
punishment on herself
yeah you bring up the the
the weird choice of the of continuing to
wear the um earrings and i was looking
at that too when i was going through old
scenes like all of my favorite scenes of
them together she's wearing them and the
one time that i see her take them off
and put something else on is after they
do the ken wins uh
uh scam and they wake up together like
after they act that actually brings them
together as a couple you know as at
least as far as we we know on on screen
that's where we first see them
get intimate and
the next morning that's the only time so
far in the scenes that i've watched that
she puts on the different pair of
earrings so it's interesting
andrew andry thank you for your uh your
super chat here for me thanks to for to
all of you for making bcs content
i got a little off topic one here really
quick anthony anthony monahan thank you
for the 499 euro
on
on
an unrelated series any thoughts on the
future of the expanse
i i don't have any thoughts right now i
i feel like it's uh
we've seen the last of it i hope that
they do pull out the last three books
because they're fantastic books but um
i don't know of anything that's coming
in the you know in the near future as
far as seeing those adapted to the tv
show
stephen brunell thank you for the five
in 606 kim's mom tells her nip it in the
bud do you think that that
that the title for nippy has some
possible relation to this i feel like it
might courtney brought this up a few
minutes ago she thought that there might
be a connection there
um
i mean mostly with their names that they
have double meaning so i i do think that
they'll be the most obvious one will be
true that it's about it being cold and i
think there's a good chance that that is
indication that we're going to see our
first um
gene gene flash forward
but yeah there's it's gonna it'll it'll
it should also have a different meaning
and it could be that
um
you know we'll see
ed sis hands thank you for the 4.99 what
are your thoughts on them jumping even
further in the timeline past the gene
timeline
i've kind of already touched on this
earlier um
i i don't really want i don't really
need personally i don't need to see them
go past
gene's decision you know his his his
decision at the end
um
they could do that i mean i think i
think historically this always kind of
turns out bad whenever they show you
know far into the future at the end of a
tv series or a movie
any of you guys want to add anything
more to that idea
i can't see them going any further i
don't see a need
i agree yeah
you know
chase
just say no not in this show but i've
always wondered if one day you know
maybe years down the line vince has an
idea if they could do just a straight up
breaking bad sequel and not even with
the same characters like with a totally
new cast just something drug or cartel
related but within the same universe
yeah we kind of talked about this a lot
in the in the last stream on on tuesday
of like you know there i don't i i
wouldn't want that personally but
we might be in the period of time
whenever that's inevitable because i
mean look you guys have been talking
about walking dead i mean look how many
shows they're still spinning off of that
at this point
that's surprising
at canada already to be honest with you
yeah as i'm saying it's like you know
it's very it's very possible that there
be other other properties that come out
of the um
of this universe that aren't necessarily
you know that where vincent and peter
don't really have a a
a big involvement but they still somehow
get made
i mean like
vince and peter have always been so
weary of you know they don't want to
milk that well dry or whatever but i
have faith in them like i don't think
they're kind of like you know walking
dead or maybe
some other
shows that have spin-off series that are
kind of i know that vince only does
stuff if he has a really good idea and i
have faith in them and personally i
wouldn't mind it if they did
another netflix movie if they did
another show obviously take a few year
break only dude if you have a good idea
but i have faith in them if they have a
good idea i say go for it don't feel bad
about milking that cow because what they
do is great and they only get better and
better the more they go
yeah i think it's just a matter of time
too i mean they've been doing it for
basically 15 years maybe more than that
at this point right so look at it this
way too compared to walking dead because
uh you know um chase and i are both fans
of walking dead i used to be a fan of
walking dead and they've had so many
show runners over the course
of the series whereas look at look at
better call saul and breaking bad you
got vincent peter
right
so that that is doable i i'm not i don't
necessarily think i want to see
something else
a sequel to it but if if it means
anything it's just the two of them since
day one so i think that could really
help
at least they're ending on a note where
i i would i would still definitely watch
anything that that takes place in this
in this universe you know i mean like
i haven't kept up with any of the the
walking dead spin-offs but you know the
this my interest is still at a place
where i would i would watch it no matter
what you know
i don't know i just want to see i guess
it doesn't even have to be in the
breaking bad universe i would just like
to see vince peter tom and the same crew
do another show together i just i would
like to see what what they would have in
store next
yeah yeah
and um i
i just just want to throw it out there
we're we're coming up on two hours so if
any of you guys whenever you're you're
at your limit just let me know because
that i've got a ton of questions here i
still gotta answer so i'm going to i'm
going to go back through them but if you
find a point where you're you want to
bow out just let me know okay i'll
probably jump top of the hour myself
here
okay all right
devin bryant thank you for the five
great panel love all your channels odin
kirk said in an interview this week
there's yet another iteration of jimmy
on his way
what might this mean i've had the same
question i saw that interview and i
wasn't exactly sure what he was saying
um do you guys believe that this means
that there's another
what i thought initially was that this
is what gene does whenever he
he you know
takes care of it himself is that that
the general consensus or do you think
that he's hinting i mean i think that
when gene does that based on all of the
stuff we've been saying for the last two
hours that he's not exactly going to be
saul again he may do some of the things
that saul does he may uh you know get
into scamming mode again like slipping
jimmy you know and what he was with with
kim but i think the the the the other
iteration it means that
the
the jimmy post gene what do you guys
think i agree with that
yeah i agree with that too so
i think we were kind of already talking
about this a little bit about like him
coming back maybe potentially to
albuquerque to
you know um because he's tired of
running so i don't think he would be
returning to saul saul was a mask jean
is a mask jimmy is the real person at
least you know that that's how i think
of him as as jimmy is is the real person
and everything else is just a facade so
maybe that's what that means like
returning to
to jimmy
chase you have anything you want to add
there
uh no no no not necessarily honestly
okay
yeah i i think you know jimmy the guy
who wants
who wants to find love you know or the
one that wants everybody to like him um
who needs love i think that's true that
is his core
chandrika sunwall thank you for the two
dollars kim's lawyer oath teaser her
re-entering law yeah we talked about
this a little bit earlier
um
i don't know what else i could add to it
but the the idea is it could either be a
flashback to
the first time she became a lawyer that
could be uh you know her remembering
that or it could be
her re-entering the law it's really hard
to say because
both of those things don't necessarily
you know have an instant place where
they fit in
bowl robot bowl
raga thank you for the a5 five dollars
um
they haven't yet touched on the time
machine book flashback episode also
noticed the buck jones poster
and kim's room was on a slant in 608 um
the time machine yeah i i don't know uh
did anybody here have a great idea of
why they decided to use that
early on in this in this season
i've read it i mean i know what it's
about but
i i don't i never really
had a great
idea of of how it it it you know it
was the right choice for for this
i thought it just might be um sort of an
indication that we would be jumping back
and forth in time a little bit right so
don't expect linear storytelling and we
certainly got that in the most recent
episode at the very end right it's quite
a jump forward
[Music]
yeah that was the best i could do
basically that we were going to move
through time but um
you know
that's that's all i got and and the buck
jones poster i i read people saying that
that
was noticeably
off in the gym in this scene that the
picture was up right there and that it
would be important but i don't know how
um and i didn't catch it myself
anybody have anything on that one
okay
zombie woods thank you for the savvy
woods thank you for the 4.99 i've heard
skylar worked for a taxi dispatch
company
anyway canada connected to bcs um
that's what she did after
walt was caught right
um
then i would say no
i mean i think that you know jimmy
turning himself in it may be involved
with going back to albuquerque but
i don't i don't really get i don't have
a
reason why she would relocate to
i guess the implication here is that
might be related to jeff right
i mean jeff could have worked for her
i guess if you really
think about it but
to me my answer would be no i don't
think it's connected
what do you guys think agreed
same yeah all right
aaron 499 marion is kim's professor at
veterinarian school
uh
yeah it brings up an interesting
question about that book we we haven't
seen that book change hands yet and um
not not that that's really something i
need to see but there was a name that
could have been mary in inside that book
isn't that right chase
the guy who uh
the guy who decoded that then wasn't
there something that could have
um
i don't recall seeing uh seeing any
marion in that book
yeah i saw a post
it was a word it was one where the name
you couldn't read the whole thing but
the m.a was definitely there and
people were were theorizing that
marion was a known associate of calderas
and that's why you know she would be a
criminal when she got introduced to the
story
what was that in episode 606 i mean i
could try and check that real quick
honestly
yeah it's been a while since i saw it so
i i'm not sure but it there was there
was definitely a post uh that that
theorized that
one of those one of those entries was
marion
um
i'm just looking through the photos i
have of that guy that did that decoded
it from reddit um
no i don't see anything that is even
close to marion honestly
all right
um
we'll move on craig otto thank you for
the five this is for eric forgive me if
you've done this on your show i'm newish
to you but could we hear you
with the guitar in parentheses rip on
the bcs theme on this stream sometime
i'd love to do it but i'd probably get
paid a copyright strike so i don't want
to do that but oh yeah it could build
copyright strike for sure
but thank you
yeah that sucks that that's such a
reality
i could play the uh severance theme on
piano for you sometime i don't know if
that will count
but
i learned that a few weeks ago so that
was fun well here's the thing that
people don't realize so let's say we're
at a two hour mark right now if i played
that tonight and if i only played for
five seconds
the copyright strike would come
robotically of course there's not people
sitting on a computer doing it it's all
robotic yeah but he would get pete would
get penalized for the entire video not
just the 30 seconds or five seconds so
he would lose any monetization or
anything for the entire video it's just
not fair but it's just a cover that's
ridiculous yeah
some are worse than others like the
eagles band is the worst if you can't
even go
and they'll nail you
yeah oh my goodness
but thank you
yeah i don't want to go on a rabbit hole
here because it's so easy to do about it
but all the problems with the auto
detecting but i just i thought about
that recently because the one the one
teaser trailer it had that really great
song
um
and you know you can't i couldn't
include that in in the video that i made
about it because you just you just can't
do that at all
oh where i first showed the
clip at the end of saul in his house
that the one you're talking about yeah
when i put that in my video i had to
like
kind of
chop it up and make it quiet other than
i don't know it was this whole thing
it's one of the things that we do is
content creators
yeah yeah
this is the name this uh one thing
that's cool about this name is that i
always recognize it and i'm always happy
to see it again but also can never uh
never
pronounce it thank you for the
699 canadian thoughts on mike's story
going forward 609 seems like a
satisfying end to his bcs story
but it's hard to imagine him not being
in the final four i think for me i think
that mike or even gus could show up in
that in either you know
you know
in that
uh
you know in the breaking bad timeline
obviously they died during that so
um
but i just don't think that i think it
would be in the service of jimmy's story
or you know maybe walton
and jesse i don't think there's anything
else that they need to really
do except for like what chase was
mentioning earlier they could show
a little bit of the tension that exists
between um mike and and jimmy that they
they didn't really put a fine point on
that before the end of the series i
guess they're they're not very friendly
they're well they're definitely not
friends i guess ever but they're not as
as
you know
warm to each other as they are in the
better call saul timeline i think
anything you guys want to see with mike
going forward
i'd be happy with one more
i don't care what it is just one more
yeah
i think it'd be cool to see something
that mike did uh before episode
213 when he's first introduced in
breaking bad like around the time that
saul first gets introduced around
episode a to season two i think it'd be
cool
see that
yeah it's there's nothing really
specific though you know i mean i think
that's the big takeaway for me
yeah
cackazado thank you for the two euro i
think kim comes back as a lawyer that's
uh something we were talking about
earlier i think that's possible
as his hands thanks for the 9.99 i think
it would make sense for gene to ask him
to turn him in and gene pleads guilty
then kim won't feel bad about accepting
the 5 million
and the oath is her using the money to
start a pro bono
yeah and we did talk about this also
earlier and um
mixed uh mixed thoughts on it
if any of you guys want to add anything
else
feel free
while i'm scrolling here
i me i mean i feel like even if gene
does turn himself in there's still the
whole thing with kim having a problem
with the fact that she got away from it
or with it and even if she didn't i mean
it's still the fact that she has to live
with what happened
regardless of if they face consequences
for it or not like it's simply something
that you just cannot really undo
and i don't think that any amount of
money or
you know accepting consequences could
even really fix that which is something
that she has to live with
yeah that's one of the points i made in
my in my recap video was that at a
certain point
you know
her her idea with the pro bono stuff was
that it it balanced out the bad you know
and that's sort of what jimmy even
brings up at the last moment there he's
like you know what about your clients
what about all the people you're helping
and i think they're just they're you
know if you're being honest there's a
there's a point where you can't just
you can't fix certain things by just
continuing to tip the scales right i
mean you know that that you realize that
you're just chasing you know it's sort
of like the sunk
cost fallacy that was you know played a
part earlier like
you could keep chasing it but you're
never gonna there's never gonna be a
point where you're like okay now the
good outweighs the bad the bad still
exists no matter what
yeah i mean it is to a certain extent
there can be some sort of yin yang if
you equal it out but if you just do a
lot of bad and then a little bit of good
and then a lot of bad again and then
just a little bit of good i mean doesn't
really even itself out at all and at
some points it's impossible to
yeah
far enough down that bad choice road
no return
eric do do you need to do do i need to
give you an off ramp here or yeah you
can you can kick me off you could kick
me off that bad choice road
i i just i'm just anticipating the next
few minutes where i just jumped from one
question to the next so i just wanted to
you know probably we're up for air i
wanted to give you a chance if you
wanted to go because you said top of the
hour and we're 10 past i'm i'm i think
i'm the oldest person here on the panel
and i got this old man needs to get
sleep
yeah i'm not sure about that we might be
in about the same but we'll we'll talk
we'll talk about the other talk off off
the air but yeah all right well it was
great having you um you can uh
you should definitely check out eric's
uh interviews you have some do you have
some coming up you can tell us about
sure uh there's three notable ones right
now um
friday august 5th uh both vince and
peter and it was very funny last night
josh fadom from the uh the film crew
deemed them as vinter gul gu vinter
guligan or something like that gould
again so that's the name that he gave
the two of them
so vince and peter will be on together
next friday night and um no no not next
friday night august 5th and august 12th
uh bob odenkirk saul goodman himself
will be on uh with a potential
potential
lady um so that's a good one and then
coming up after that just have to
schedule the slot
the uh all three of the film students
will be on together as well too so we're
looking forward to that
uh that's cool
i i tom
i had something i want to join you on
that
i'm not sure tom tom's got an open
invitation he said he's going to be
coming back so we'll see i'm not sure
when that is but he does he definitely
wants to come back so
okay sorry chase go ahead
oh it's all good i just meant to say i
meant to catch the josh fadom i had to
watch him post but i was gonna i was
wondering um because they did that like
webisode with the uh camera crew
but in that webisode
uh
josh's uh camera guy his his uh
character's name he calls himself
marshall
which
which i found very very particular since
i thought his name was joey dixon dixon
marshall marshall joey dixon mjd we were
joking about last night yeah
there we go yeah yeah because then when
i first saw that i was like what the
heck
threw me for a loop he was really he was
really he kept the conversation going
last night he was a lot of fun
nice yeah well thank thank you pete for
having me and it's great to be here with
the the great great uh panel here i mean
the fans of all of your content love it
to death
and i'm just honored to be here it's uh
very humbled by it as well yeah and like
i said check out i have links in the
description here if you want to check
out eric's channel and um yeah thanks
for coming on we'll have you again i'm
not sure we'll see i'll i'll do a little
bit of thinking after this one and see
if i want to keep doing two per week or
how we do it but
i'll definitely be in touch and we'll
have you on either on tuesday or
saturday again so thank you so much a
pleasure i hope everyone has a nice
weekend
yeah you see you man all right take care
everybody
all right so are you guys you guys
strapped in are you here with me or do
you need to go too cause let's do it all
at once if we need yeah i'm good for a
little bit more
okay still here cool because this we had
a pile of questions here that just been
piling up so uh i'm gonna try to move
quick but it's it's difficult because i
find all of this stuff fascinating like
like i said it's just
that's why i do this i guess so here we
go captain
captain
captain murphy thank you for the five i
think gene will play pay off jeff
there's a teaser where we hear gene say
there we're done
we're not friends or something like that
yeah that was my take on that i did a
video about that i'm sure chase did a
video about that too
the the thing about it is though the
question is is that part of a bigger
play
or is that he really thinks he he can
pay him off and that's the end because
usually when you but when you pay off
blackmail the problem is is that it
never ends there you know i mean and and
gene slash jimmy saul he's smart enough
to know that you know
usually if you if you give somebody a
taste they're going to keep coming back
for that whenever they need it so just
telling asking them nicely like we're
not friends and stay away
it's it's not very realistic to me
i mean i'm paraphrasing here but i'm
pretty sure specifically what he says in
that trailer is if you think of coming
back for more don't
so i mean he should know that if he you
know blackmail's gonna come back you
know i mean how much
i was gonna bring up charlie sheen there
for a second you know like
he just just keeps going
yeah i i think it's a typic difficult
thing you know and i think that he would
know about that so my long story short i
think that that's part of a bigger
bigger plan you know
yeah
raven scene thank you for the five
dollars canadian to what degree are the
writers constrained to write a story
which doesn't spoil breaking bad when
watched after yeah i was kind of
touching on this earlier it didn't it
was it was kind of just thrown in there
with that but
yeah i mean i think they do have to
take it into consideration that one bcs
should stand on its own
and then two that it shouldn't ruin any
of the surprises that happen in the
natural progression in case someone
watches the prequel before the sequel
you know or the before the original
series
i don't know
any
anybody else have anything they want to
add to that well i think i don't think
they are constrained i mean because
they're going in with the assumption
like if it was just better call saul and
the jimmy storyline maybe but
if you find out what happens to gene
that does spoil
what happens in breaking bad and there's
there's like flashbacks and other bits
of backstory that we get in and breaking
bad that i wonder how people that
haven't seen breaking bad or
understanding better call self for
example
um gus's feud with the cartel in the
salamancas and what happened to
max right so i wonder about things like
that like how that changes
um
their understanding of the show so i
think it's possible of course that you
can watch it out of order but i think
they're you're missing a lot
and certainly how i think probably these
last four are going to spoil breaking
bad yeah yeah
it's kind of like you know whenever you
read books like i almost always like to
read publication order instead of
chronological order whenever it's like
you know some
epic series or something like that
i like to think about it how they how
they made it rather than you know
thinking about it historically what
happens inside the world or something
like that
i mean people can watch it however they
want like for example there's this thing
called chronologically lost where they
took the lost show and put everything in
order of the way that things actually
happen and i know that some people like
watching them see you movies in
chronological timeline order or the star
wars movies but you know for star wars i
watch four five six and then one two
three um and the thing is is i was
thinking about showing one of my friends
who hasn't seen better call saul i was
or breaking bad i was going to show them
better call salt first and then breaking
bad but then i thought well the gene
would kind of
they wouldn't understand the the gene
scene and what's going on there and i
mean if it was just
like okay maybe saul has moved away and
he's living as someone else why did he
change his name but they laid out what
that you know he's in hiding he told ed
that he got made we saw the 405 flash
forward of him
calling ed like they've made a point to
show how
jimmy and saul become gene in better
call saul without needing to see
breaking bad um so there's still that
mystery of why but
just knowing that that eventually
happens i mean we'll have to see what
happens in the next four episodes but
they've definitely
they've definitely made better cross-all
with the
imp or with the assumption that you've
seen breaking bad like when gus first
appeared in season three they did it
kind of the same way in breaking bad but
they did it in such a way where
gus is walking past jimmy but he's kind
of blurred and you don't see his face at
first because
they think that you already know what
gus looks like so they wait for that
reveal for when he approaches jimmy when
he puts his watch in the trash can and
then you see gus's face so just moments
like that they assume you've already
seen breaking bad
yeah and i guess you're right i mean you
know it goes it goes both ways and if i
was going to tell somebody to watch uh i
would tell them to watch breaking bad
first
yeah
agreed
alexander
jovanovich says or thank you for the two
pound hector would have continued
looking for proof in breaking bad
question mark
hector would have continued looking for
proof and breaking bad
um
maybe but i think the last episode did a
pretty good job of showing just how it
doesn't matter you know
there's not really much he can do
because the laudio
uh
doesn't care
he's an earner
yeah
and i mean and it's kind of like i said
it's almost like you can almost feel
sorry or feel bad for for hector briefly
when you don't think about just
what an awful human being his character
is
but i mean that is something that
they've they've stretched all the way
down the line you know the reason why
lala was
doing all of what he was doing was
because he needed proof before he could
he could actually
make again make a move against gus you
know
and everyone involved knows that that
they don't really matter that they if
they're
if they get killed someone else is going
to take their place the machine is still
going to go you know what i mean the
cartel is is
it doesn't really care about individuals
that cares about making money it's like
a corporation
i mean that's what happens in real life
too right like how long does someone
really lead a cartel and once one boss
is out and another cartel takes their
spot
i mean
i know that narcos is dramatized or
whatever but i used to be super into
into that show and that kind of stuff
happens all the time
yeah and we're at this we're we've come
full circle on this
morty smith um
quote from before
thank you for the 199. he's rewriting
his theory i'm i'm trying to read it
here uh saul will put one lap pull one
last trick and will talk himself out of
trouble one last time with the help of
kim
they will make an elaborate story that
jimmy is a victim and will use real
events to support it walt and jesse
kidnapped jimmy
cartelle burned my brother
lalo killed howard etc
they will add more scenes and details in
breaking bad timeline over the next few
episodes to add more
supporting details to help they will do
some prep post breaking bad timeline
with help of kim kim will serve as
witness and testify to support jimmy's
story
and other people
like cliff maine
um
let's see it goes on for a little bit
more i have a general idea what you're
talking about here
i mean i can kind of see it i think it
goes against where they're at
right now character-wise i think they
would there have to be some pretty big
changes that would happen
what do you guys think about
this the the the the general premise is
that um
the the one last uh you know the last
trick will be for
saul to talk himself out of trouble
and kim will help him do that
oh my god
uh
i'm not too sure honestly he has a
rushing day
rushing to give your opinions i was i
was trying to read that
to that it's really difficult to read a
multi-part uh it was like it was like
six six different comments or whatever i
was thinking maybe if you could try and
condense it a little bit but yeah
so
basically kim will come back and help
him get off right that's that's the
general idea so i mean that was
something we did talk about earlier a
little bit like if she takes her oath
again could she possibly defend jimmy um
but i don't i i don't see this having
like any sort of happy ending and i
think him getting away with it would be
too much of a happy ending or
maybe happy isn't the correct word to
use here but there if he needs to there
needs to be consequences for what he has
done
i think yeah it kind of undercuts the
whole idea of reckoning right
but you know like there are four
episodes and and things could change you
know
there could be reasons but yeah um right
now like that's that's where i would
that's where i would go with that i
would say that i don't i don't
anticipate it but you know things could
change
andrea uh thanks for 750 isk
it's very exotic looking i don't know
what it is but
it's very nice of you either way my
favorite moment was when cliff maine
aided kim in her lie by refusing to
comment great writing great setup yeah
that's something i mentioned in my video
is that you know
poor cliff he's like
uh
i've seen too much and all of it was
completely
set up by
kim and jimmy you know
that's the thing too it sucks so much
how kim pretty much destroyed the two
people that were still defending the
fact that howard is innocent and that he
wasn't a drug addict and
she essentially gasleth them into
believing the lie like the two final
people that were willing to defend that
he wasn't an addict
and
like
like she brings up saying how
she
didn't say anything and she wished she
did and then cheryl kind of looks over
to cliff and says well did you
uh know anything about this did you see
any examples and he kind of says like oh
this isn't the time or place
yeah
but that probably made him feel really
guilty like oh crap maybe i should have
said something too what the heck so
exactly i was gonna i was gonna say the
same thing chase so yeah that was kind
of um
a dig at a cliff definitely so the i
wish i'd said something and he's sitting
there thinking like well i've had all
this evidence shown to me and i didn't
say anything so i think that's certainly
something he could wrestle with and it
reminds me a little bit of the moment
when um howard is in the apartment
following chuck's death and he's
confessing that he thinks that he may
have um contributed to to what chuck did
because he asked him to resign and very
callously uh jimmy's like well that's
your cross to bear so it very much
reminded me of that moment and also just
linguistically the i wish i had like i
wish i'd said something also reminds me
a little bit of a line from her mother
where she says she's going to wish we'd
call it the police so again as part of
the fiction of like you know
you know uh showing how how you know
she's a
not moralistic in this moment but like
you know she's regretting her own
decisions and
um projecting that on to them
it's just crazy how she how kim pushes
the guilt on to yeah cliff and cheryl in
kind of a similar way that jimmy pushed
the guilt on to howard those are just
moments that just like i look at that
season four episode and i still just
like my heart sinks like i was i'm doing
it for my tier list i was doing it for
i did a video on all the reasons why
jimmy and kim hate howard and i was i've
looked over that scenes quite that scene
quite a few times recently and it just
gets me every time and i feel like this
is another one of those scenes
that is just going to get me every
single time with how they just gaslit
the final two people that believed in
howard and they completely ruined that
for them
yeah
true shoes thank you for the five
dollars canadian i think gene will
return to albuquerque to tie up loose
ends like walt one example i'm thinking
of is him telling cheryl the truth so
she gets closure
uh i don't know
uh
cheryl
it'd be too little too late but i'd like
it be too little too late though
especially after all those years
and i feel like that would be him like
it would sort of be like that thing
where you unburden yourself and you
think you're helping the other person
but you're you're not really you're
bringing up old wounds that that can't
really be resolved like it
i i don't know um
i think that he could tie up some loose
ends but um
i'm not sure that that's one of the ones
that would would really
be all that noble
that definitely would be trying to
unburden yourself the same way that mike
tried talking to nacho's dad but nacho's
dad just didn't give him any sort of
satisfaction in doing so
sorry to cut you
oh no no i off
just thinking so like in breaking bad
after um walt and jesse burned down the
lab right i was thinking if like further
down in the future if they decide some
some company corporation decides to
build something else on the lot there if
it's possible that they might recover
the bodies
under the lab
and um
i don't know if that's something that
they would bother doing but i was just
thinking of of how that would be proof
then for for cheryl for cliff that you
know um i think there's i think there's
opportunity for it for that story to
come out and i really think that line
that they threw in there with mike and
gus that the file can't be closed until
you know as long as there's no body i
think is something to bear in mind
whether they the writers follow that
through and pick up on that line um is a
question
that i don't know we'll have to wait and
see if they answer that but i do think
it's it's an interesting question
that perhaps will be addressed will the
body be recovered
yeah i had a ton of people saying oh gus
is definitely going to hunt her down now
and and i don't think that's necessarily
the case but i do think what you're
saying is true they they definitely gave
themselves that out in the storytelling
you know i mean that's that's a thread
they can pull on
i'm not sure if they will but um
yeah i had a lot of people saying oh
well well gus is surely going to hunt
her down now the one thing that is kind
of interesting though is that
he did say you know mike told him told
them very specifically you're not going
to change anything you're going to do
exactly what you do
and then she turned around and she quit
the law and left town like not really
following uh
his instructions at all there
don't do anything major don't draw
attention towards yourself oh well i'm
not a lawyer and i'm moving away oh
that's not suspicious at all
yeah so i i kind of one in the same in
the same way i kind of wonder if they're
gonna if they're gonna that's gonna play
a part you know
he had one they had one normal day and
that's it that's good enough i convinced
cheryl i'm out
yeah i don't know like we thought that
or at least i thought i know other
people are theorizing that after uh
episode 608 that maybe gus could go
after kim because he knows where he
lives he kind of knows what he looks
like he knows that he whoever lives at
that house is involved with the cartel
and you could easily look up and find
out that gus frank the owner of los
poyos works there so yada yada maybe kim
finds out gus's true
business and maybe he goes after her but
they kind of closed that in 609 with
mike telling gus that the lawyers did
their part and they played it almost too
well so i don't think that gus is going
to go after kim and likewise i don't
think that he's going to go after cheryl
or anyone else on the lawyer side of the
show i think that that's over and done
with but i did get a
a lot of comments that are like oh when
they when hank and gomey you know search
the super lab and breaking bad they
found the two bodies even though those
are the two bodies that
the guards that walt killed or whatever
so there is that discrepancy but you
know maybe they could
could do another or oh yeah the new
people decided to build there and they
found two random burials
one block 1980
ostrom 1980 thank you for the five that
this is about the same thing and when i
was reading his i just thought about the
the idea that we have moved on from this
timeline so you know like
it's it's odd that that she did that but
it doesn't seem like there are any
immediate um reactions from them because
we did i don't know that we're going to
go back to the you know the bcs timeline
at all
yeah and i don't mean i don't know that
the cops
would still be interested in talking to
them or following them if they're
satisfied with with what the story they
were they were told and she's in pro
bono practice so
um i mean certainly other people in the
community will notice that she's missing
so that is it is an interesting
uh question i think yeah the monte
morick
thank you for the two do you guys
foresee any more deaths uh for me i
think that gus is gonna die
i think that mike's gonna die
walter white is going to die
what about you guys no don't don't
don't get crazy
oh god there's some crackpot theories
you got there man
oh my goodness i don't think jimmy or
kim will die no that i guess that's what
the question is right i i don't think so
yeah yeah i agree i think that any
deaths would happen in the better case
all timeline i don't think gene's gonna
die i think kim got out um
who else survives i don't think we're
gonna see jesse i don't think you know
i don't think anyone on the lawyer's
side is gonna die i think cliff is fine
rich is fine cheryl's fine
uh
stacy and kaylee are fine
joe the guy from the junkyard he's fine
skinny pete badger they're fine i don't
know
i could foresee maybe maybe gene dying
but like jimmy uh but
i don't think so and i don't think kim
is gonna die so i think it's it's an
interesting um
interesting question though because i
was thinking of like pairings in this
universe and in every couple someone
dies so jessie jane jesse andrea walt
schuyler hank marie
uh so
i don't know i don't know i i don't i
don't think they're gonna go that way
though
yeah i didn't think about that but
you're right um
all right next one thank you for the
five andre
w
sarkis maybe
uh eventually they'd find lalo and
howard under the lab when they excavate
that hole in the ground
maybe in the gene timeline that's
something we were just talking about and
um i don't have anything else to add on
it um
other than i don't think they report
yeah i don't think it's a given that
they would find those bodies
they're buried under thick concrete
and you know there's
it's a thing that they could it's a
thread they could pull on but i don't
think that i would feel like it was a
a plot hole or a mistake for them not to
to ever be found
i mean like
that that basement for the super lab was
built in seeker right like is that just
part of the real estate now
like for all we know the next people
that buy that plot of land they could
just fill up that hole with a bunch of
concrete or something right
i mean it was a meth lab though i mean
certainly oh yeah the police and
yeah they're going to they might
be curious about what's underneath there
there and it might take a while for them
to discover it
so it could come up i wouldn't be
surprised either way if they do or they
don't
yeah i mean it's it's it could be a
toxic dump site too like there's a lot
of things that just sort of i don't
really know about how that would go out
and go down in real life so i don't i
don't really
speculating on it doesn't really make
sense from my point of view because i
just don't know enough like but like you
said is
did they just destroy the whole thing
after that you know what i mean like
that seems like what they would do in
real life but does that mean if they did
that would they find something that was
buried under you know all that concrete
i'm not sure
yeah i feel like they'd be more likely
to fill it up than dig more out
yeah i'm scrolling through this because
this comment here is is a is in relation
to that that theory we talked about a
second ago the and
i'm scrolling through the chat but i i
get i don't
it's apparent that people don't really
realize how many
chat uh
how chat scrolls by in here and how i
can't really keep up with everything
because this thing is going on for like
minutes here where they're talking about
the that same um
theory
and yeah
uh support it i don't know what the
point of this is in the context that
walt and jesse kidnapped they um they do
kidnap saul in episode
eight of season two of breaking bad
and and he could he could use that as a
uh
you know as a as part of his
explanation for why he did what he did
but you don't get out of crimes just
because someone forced you to do them
you're still you're still actually
guilty of them
yeah so
and we got some spam in there too sorry
about that
uh
duel dyer thank you for the five do you
guys think kim is still alive by the end
of the gene timeline and will he reunite
with jimmy
well we just all three said that we
thought that she would probably survive
and
i mean the thing with reuniting is it
it's just such a big thing how could
they not do it in a way but um
i don't know anything else to add on
that
uh yeah i i really like the final scene
with kim in 609 but i do think it's a
bit too short and uh
sudden for it to be the last time we
ever see her definitely think we're
gonna see her again
and peter i think we might have talked
about this but just as far as all the
main characters having sort of a
different ending right like
jessie
uh or walt dies jesse lives but goes
into hiding maybe gene goes into hiding
but then he goes into jail and then kim
just gets to live free so i think it'd
be nice for them to have all
different outcomes from this criminal
life
yeah that's the way i see it like i
don't know i like how walt dies jesse
lives a new life
gene goes to jail
be nice doesn't repeat the same ending
i don't remember if it was vince or
peter one of them said though that we've
never seen anyone actually go and face
like actual real time like you know
maybe uh short stints in jail so they
were at some point i don't know if this
sounds familiar to either of you i can't
remember which one of them said it
but it would be an interesting take if
someone actually has to go to prison and
serve actual time
for what they've done and as far as
whether we'll see kim again i i tend to
think we we haven't seen the last of her
i don't know if we're gonna see her
again with jimmy i do think we're going
to see a phone call though perhaps yeah
so
i think that is an important part i've
seen a lot of theories this week too
about that about how
maybe she'll come back and we'll see how
they set those calls up like
she could appear in the breaking bad
timeline i do think that the implication
is that she left albuquerque there's no
reason for her
to stay there
especially after she quits the law so
i saw some things that like maybe she's
just living there and and she's just
hanging around but they don't they don't
get together anymore i think it's more
likely if we saw her in the breaking bad
timeline it would be that she was
passing through or she reaches out to
him and possibly sets up those those
telephone calls because
if they're addicts and they think that
they're bad for each other then
it's not really great to to tempt each
other with knowing too much about what's
going on in each other's lives right
i definitely think that kim isn't in
albuquerque anymore like she knows too
many people from her lawyer career and i
think just like how she doesn't want to
be in that apartment anymore because the
apartment's tainted maybe the whole
town's tainted for her so i think that
she's definitely in another town and if
we do see kim in the breaking bad or
gene timeline like post breaking bad i
would like to see her reaction to seeing
the uh the heisenberg case on tv kind of
like how we saw within el camino with uh
skinny pete and badger watching it and
then jesse hearing about walt's death on
the on the car radio so i'd like to see
uh
see kim's reaction to uh the heisenberg
case and maybe implications with saul or
the fact that saul's missing or or he's
wanted or something like that
yeah and actually i mentioned earlier
that i was
maybe like how they were going to do
walt and jesse i mentioned like a
scenario like potentially like when
jesse's hiding out hiding out in the
laser tag plays
um mike is looking for him
that might be an interesting
point to jump into and something else
that i was thinking of is how like that
might also relate to kim because i'm
sure that was probably national news
once um
once gus was killed right so like you
have like this this explosion at a
nursing home and it involves big members
of the cartel she certainly knows the
salamanca name um she may not know who
gus is but she might recognize um boyos
hermanos and stuff like that so i
thought that might be interesting as
well so it to see um maybe not just at
the end with waltz but at some other
point along the storyline chase
where uh she's watching something on the
news
yo was it an el camino as well where uh
joe the guy from the junkyard he sees
like a uh
news story of uh how jessie's wanted or
something like that so you can see the
same thing with uh with saul as well
yeah
yeah that that's that's an interesting
point i mean she that would be
nationwide wouldn't it
yeah there's a there's a definite
possibility that you would see that no
matter where you are
i mean i looked up the uh like how much
saul was wanted for in that bounty
poster compared to like the top 10 in
america and he'd he'd definitely be like
number three
hmm
matthew reeves thank you for the two
dollars he says walt is teaching class
and jessie's in the back
we're kind of past that though in the
timeline right now
i'm not sure if we'll go backwards
this one is a little bit confusing to me
i've been looking at it for about 30
seconds and
walt and jesse scenes
walton gus
jesse and saul
walt and jesse with saul
go sox
i think that might be a reference to i
think it was brian cranston one of them
said that there were three scenes all
together one was them together and then
one was of each of them separately so
maybe this is what
um yeah
speculating
there should be three scenes all
together okay yeah because
jesse
yeah now i see
yeah now i see that there's a uh colon
there so
walt and gus
jesse and saul
walt and jesse and saul yeah okay
rory
gogurty thank you for the five euro do
you think jay and kay
jimmy and kim could meet again but not
reunite
she could be remarried kids a new job or
could things turn out tragically for her
yeah we talked about this a little bit
ago i hope you heard it um
that's what i think is that there would
have to be some kind of shift i think
that she's i think she's going to a dark
place even though she's making the right
decision like i don't think that
um you know she's just going to be so
it's going to be so easy for her to put
all this behind her and live a new life
not not right
immediately after the the events of
episode 9.
orga
something 15 i can't i can't make that
out kim said the relationship was
poisoned to both of them but it's
actually just for her
jimmy's even worse alone
uh jimmy's even worse alone maybe kim
find out she's just the same
yeah there's a possibility to that um
but i think that the point there is more
of it about the fact that you know
it's it's like an addiction you know
there's progression they got worse as
they went and there's really no stopping
it just keeps going
when they're together she's hoping that
if they get apart then they might be
okay
right
stuff it definitely has to do with the
whole wine and roses of it all right
i mean you're saying here that jimmy's
worse alone it's i don't know that
that's really true it but but jimmy's
strategy after she leaves is is
definitely not
you know what you would hope he would do
he he basically takes all of the jimmy
and humanity out of himself and he just
he just throws himself into
uh this life wearing this mask i mean i
think peter gould called it he flattened
himself out into being a cartoon
character
right
so
i don't think she could anticipate that
that's how he would react i mean she she
could if she i guess if she went back
and really
looked at
you know
what was going on but i mean it just
like anything with people it's it's
there's so many different factors it's
just really complicated you know
she's he's thinking of it more than the
lines of like
they they're part of the glue that keeps
them together is the scheming and the
scheming will always
it'll always have negative consequences
and on you know stuff that they can't
account for
well jimmy or kim always had that inside
of her because of her past and with her
mom but she was never like that by
herself it's
jimmy's what awoken that with her and
made her like that so
maybe she's thinking if she's not with
jimmy anymore then she can go back to
not connie she just quit cold turkey and
then jimmy goes off into becoming saul
it's kind of just like the
the wine and roses story except with a
twist at the end i guess because instead
of
you know well
yeah
yeah
i'm just assuming you guys know the wine
and roses but uh yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i actually watched it just out of
curiosity yeah i i just read the
synopsis to be honest i just read the
summary yeah so at the end he um he ends
up leaving her and uh well they both
descend into really really horrible
alcoholism and um it's been a while
since i've seen it i think he ends up in
a mental asylum and he gets out and um
yeah and then uh
she decides she goes and stays with her
father and it turns out like they have
this little kid and he's the one that
decides to to get better and it's
there's a really sad moment there's also
kind of this like pleading moment where
she comes over and she's so kind of an
inverse of what we see with jimmy and
kim where he's pleading with her to stay
she's um lee remy is that her name i
think the character actress name is
pleading with him um to uh to stay
and he's like i can't you know i can't
do this
so yeah it's a it's an inversion of of
that story
yeah i think i saw a few clips of it
because i remember that final scene of
them at the doorway with the kid but
yeah it's it's really kind of messed up
because he introduced her to alcohol but
then he gets clean and she gets worse
and worse so with jimmy and kim jimmy
introduces kim to the conning
but
if it were to fall like parallel wine
and roses jimmy would get clean and kim
would get worse and worse but it's a
twist where kim backs out and then jimmy
gets worse so i mean the parallel's
still there regardless
yeah libra mick i think that was her
name
okay
jojo's asmr thank you for the a five
dollars even a bigger hint kettleman's
run ice station zebra is in american
greed betsy says we're survivors
implying they were forced by jimmy to
work
yeah i'll agree
almeida's army thank you for the one
pound 79 will cheryl and her legal
practice come into play
i would say no
what do you guys think
i would not be surprised if we saw the
last to cheryl in this episode to be
honest i don't know if we'll see her at
all in the breaking bad timeline
through the gene timeline at all
i think i think that i think that
609 put a pretty nice bow on that
well tragic bow but and then a book end
yeah
yeah i mean unless like you know they're
they're going to pick up more with the
howard storyline maybe
telling the truth about what really
happened that night with howard uh
i don't imagine her coming back
so i do think it's it's possible though
that maybe in the final episode or two
we do
see her again in some capacity or at
least that the story will be told
yeah i think that makes sense i'm
looking through here and um
things were getting pretty uh choppy in
the in the
chat for a while
if anybody who's watching is interested
in becoming a mod uh you can email me on
the back end of my channel
and we can talk about that
but i i
i expect people to be
i don't know adults if they're here but
i guess that you can't really can't
really count on it
if there's any if there's any viewers
that uh
that have talked to me on twitter before
or anything like that maybe hit me up on
twitter and you know if i've talked to
you before you know i might might vouch
for you
just yeah yeah yeah it's
i i you know i have something i've been
thinking about i just don't know anybody
in my personal life or off top my head
that would be a good fit for it so
if you do
reach out and then we can talk about it
not just
sorry yeah r
ruari gogerty thank you for the five
pounds
chance that the
refused scholarship girl could be the
one that francesca calls hard to think
who it is
cliff main rich or oakley don't seem
likely
i've kind of landed on cliff
for who's left but um
do you guys have any other thoughts i
mean i don't the refuse scholarship girl
that would be like a deep cut at this
point
i i mean i think that that was an
interesting part of the story it was a
great scene um
christie esposito but they they haven't
really gone back to it for for quite
some time so that would seem kind of out
of the blue for me yeah i'm not sure
that we're going to actually see who
francesca calls i don't know if that's
something they'll bother including i
think the more important thing from that
scene is the tease phone call that she
will be receiving so i don't know if
we'll ever actually know the answer to
what lawyer she calls
me yeah because i i i've said this
before but i think when they made that
they didn't know and and
they weren't even sure so
us trying to reverse engineer it is not
really
you know maybe prudent
i i'm still vouching that it's still kim
i mean we haven't heard anything about
christie esposito i think the only time
that she ever came up again was when
howard was talking to jimmy in season
five trying to first offer him that job
right so
you know yeah relevant thing to pull out
of nowhere
yeah the call the call is definitely kim
that's what you're about to say too
right
i think the question is because um
jimmy says gives her the card yeah yeah
he gives her a card and says tell him
that jimmy told you to uh oh yeah okay
okay i was i was thinking of the the
birthday call not the not the card
yeah
yeah yeah i don't know i don't know i
think i think it could be could be cliff
or rich honestly
yeah
daniel chang thank you for the nt 70.
is bcs season six end of bb
bcs universe i i think so we talked
about this earlier um
they may there may be more ip that
exists in this world because that's just
the way things work but
i think this is
i i believe vince and peter when they
say they'd like to try out some
different things and they're ready to
move on and i hope they get to do that
wall of text objection thank you for the
ten dollars opinion
opinions about how jimmy handled mike's
death in breaking bad
and how that might play in jimmy's story
was it a case of jimmy
compartmentalizing again
or is walt the new lalo
that's an interesting question um
i i i i don't know does either you have
a knee jerk reaction answer to this
i think it could be him
compartmentalizing
i mean i mean the real answer is that
when they when they did that they didn't
know that jimmy and mike would have such
a backstory right because better people
saw it but like in
in universe
answer i'm not too sure i mean jesse was
the one that was really pissed off over
mike dying right i kind of wish that's
all
did show more of being mammy maybe
that's something we could see in one of
the walton jesse scenes you know like
maybe when saul's in in the in the
bunker
at ed's with with walt he could go off
about how he killed mike or something
like that
i think there's no love lost between the
two and i think we do see throughout
breaking bad just how
i mean like the scene where where mike
shows up
at his office and is going to break his
legs you know i think there's certainly
to put it you know lightly tension
between them so
um
[Music]
i don't
i
i think he saw it coming probably and
and
i i guess like i just see saul now in in
the context of what happened most
recently that this is someone that's not
like really dealing with feelings at all
right so yeah really
processing much yeah i think that's
that's where i'm landing too and the
more i think about it
i mean he's the guy that's constantly
suggesting people take trips to belize
right so yeah
the recovery 716 thank you for the 499 i
want to watch better dial lyle
how how did he become los pollos
hermanos material
you know what i think about lyle is that
that is he's eventually he's going to
learn what his boss did you know i mean
i feel kind of bad for him in that
whenever he finds out the truth about
this guy gus that he worked with for so
long
then that scene in season three when
hector came to los poyos would finally
make sense right be like oh he duped me
with that fake story
well you know
they did say uh gordon smith did say
that they have a uh a fake musical that
they that they talk about in the white
writers room about lyle
uh i mentioned this on the last stream i
think it was one or two uh
insider podcasts ago they mentioned that
whiskey thank you for the five anyone
notice mike watching isotopes game in
breaking bad season four episode one
then a very similar shot of him watching
an isotopes game again
in bcs season six episode seven or eight
uh i saw a comment about this and
uh you brought this up the scene where
he's having a beer watching tv
and i think one of the things that that
shows is like that would be his life
if he didn't work
you know if he if he didn't get mixed up
with the cartel
that that's exactly what he'd be doing
he'd be working at the parking garage
and he'd be you know watching those
baseball games i think it was also sort
of visual pun on the fun and games right
so you have the fun of the marble track
and then the game is the actual baseball
game playing
that's true yeah that's a good one
um and israeli davis thank you for the
five thomas s said this flash forward is
around 2007. he said the props don't
matter
i'm not sure if he said the props don't
matter
but he did say that i brought this up in
my last video my preview video and i
think the biggest thing altogether is
that
whatever it doesn't really matter but
what matters is that that we see how he
fl we see a flash forward to how he is
after kim leaves and it's before he
meets uh
it's before he meets walt that's the
important part the the the time frame
isn't all that important
yeah i'm gonna just send that one out
i think they made a mistake with the
with the the o5 but we'll see
uh sean looby thank you for the 10
great channel
hi courtney he says hi sean
and uh you said you're gonna get ready
to go is that right courtney i want to
give you a chance if you need it because
there's still more questions i gotta
answer so yeah so i'll go ahead and i'll
bow out here um thank you so much again
for having me on uh great great chat
nice uh chatting with you too chase
yeah yeah it was a great time
all right
have a good one
yeah so yeah
check out her channel the the link is in
the description well it was it was nice
having you we will definitely
talk more and um we'll have you back
before uh in one of these like i said
i'll be thinking about same thing i told
er you know eric i'll be thinking about
whether we're gonna do two or how that
works it sounds like you're pretty busy
on tuesdays
uh with your regular schedule so yeah
well after this week i'll have a little
bit more flexibility right so um just
this last week
and then i'll have a little bit more
freedom so yeah we'll chat for sure
all right all right well have a good one
and thanks again and we'll talk soon
all right now i'm scrolling through
the ongoing debate about this uh
theory on the side chat
rory gogerty
thank you for the five pound uh could
jimmy see kim again not everyone oh we
already read read this one didn't we
uh yeah yeah i think this is different
it's a different version of the same one
it's a different version of the same one
though her life turned out tragically
addition addiction health issues etc
uh i don't like the one i don't like the
the literal addiction
um
i think that's a little bit over the top
but i i do think that she's going to be
in a bad
spot that's where i keep going back to
that this is not going to be something
that um
you know that's gonna that she's gonna
walk away from easily
i will just add that i don't think that
kim's remarried or has kids or anything
like that i think she's still living the
single life trying to do her best to
help people
yeah i agree maybe she could be out back
at her hometown working at the hinky
dinky who knows
thank you what
that is interesting the um
you know the the
what she said there she's being
purposely vague but you wonder how much
how much truth is actually in the lie
you know what i mean
i need to look up hinky dinky red cloud
now and see if that's real
i think that's a in the in the middle of
the country that's a
uh
grocery store chain isn't it
it's not one that i've ever seen where i
lived anywhere you know
i've i've honestly never looked it up i
mean i've looked up red cloud i haven't
looked up the hinky dinky
i like saying that name though it's a
good time yeah it's a good it's a good
it's a catchy title
yeah you can see why they use it
the game 9205 thank you for the 4.99 off
topic but will you be doing any
westworld season 4 videos i probably
won't um i'm pretty busy i i don't
i am watching it i like the first three
episodes in particular and the last one
i watched i didn't like as much but um
there's a lot of people that cover it is
it's a show that takes a lot a lot of
time because it's
you know it's
at least like the last couple of seasons
been nearly incoherent
and there's a lot i like about it but
you know i mean i just don't think it
makes sense for for me right now
um if something really cool comes up
then i i might i might do it but
i've kind of moved past of like i want
to sit around and just um
obsess over westworld theories because
the payoff hasn't been that great and
seasons two and season three
brxh499
thank you if jimmy wants to be saul 24 7
post kim why does he tell walter that
his real name is mcgill when he meets
him
well he's trying to level with him right
like there's been a few times in
breaking bad that saul actually acts
like jimmy he has a few moments of
humanity like when tell saul maybe
should leave the game or
or maybe you should turn himself in and
stop stuff like that like he does have a
few moments they're rare but here and
there where he
tries leveling with people like a human
being
yeah and i just don't think there's any
reason that he needs to conceal it from
it
it does it's not that he wants to be
saul 24 7. it's his way of of coping
with the situation he's wearing a mask
what could he what could actually
hap you know how could that come back on
him in any negative way for him to say
what his real name is
everyone knows that's a fake name like
nobody's born
saul good man
yeah
i mean even hey maybe they only
you know he's he's clearly you know it
to me it seems like it's a you know it's
definitely something that he made up
himself
jacques doucet uh thank you for the 10
huge twist ahead sammy hagar shows up
with jebs the cab driver
yeah i i can't i i can't wait till we
actually get to gene that's what i was
thinking the last couple of days like
we've we've been waiting so long you
know what i mean
yeah yeah it's just wild just still
predicting off of the same season five
stuff from like two years ago
like literally two years you know in the
real world yeah like i got i got a i got
a video about a gene and kim reunion
from like a year and a half two years
ago honestly you know
oh lala salamanca is here thank you for
the two dollars
gene and marco wear a suit
in the end
for shadow
jean and marco
oh marco he he's wearing a suit whenever
he plays dead or plays like he's passed
out in the alley is that what we're
talking about here
yeah i assume so
marco never met that's what
so
yeah i mean he he does that because
that's how they make the the rolex look
legit instead of being fake right if a
guy who's wearing a suit has it on
yeah he wouldn't be wearing he wouldn't
be wearing a fake
i'm not sure if it's foreshadowing um
some guy thank you for the five what are
y'all's thoughts on that supposed other
description of 610 on that spanish
streaming service
i'm not sure
i'm not sure if what i'm thinking about
is what they're talking about but i
heard a supposed description for the
next episode i'm not sure if it's true
or not i don't know if i should put it
in the i haven't heard it i didn't just
say it i don't know if it's like a
spoiler or not or fair enough it's no
it's out there in the world it's not a
spoiler i heard that and i don't know if
this is true or not it could just be
someone you know josh and me but i heard
that
carol burnett plays a neighbor and jean
gets close to her in order to get close
to her son in order to pull off a con
with her son
i'm not sure if that's true or not but i
heard that through the grapevine either
on twitter and a youtube comment and
honestly forgot about it until like
halfway through the stream here didn't
really
have any time to just randomly throw it
in i think it was a description of an
episode but i'm not sure
well that's that's my favorite theory on
carol burnett is that she's she's in the
gene timeline and she's a snag in the
in whatever he tries to do
against jeff you know
i haven't seen that i didn't see the
spanish streaming service uh description
in question i don't know if it's exactly
the same one even because
i don't know i'm guessing there's a post
on on reddit or somewhere that i haven't
seen yet but um
i'm gonna look for it thanks for the
heads up
and yeah just like what i said i i i
like the idea that she could be related
to jeff
that's been one of my favorite
ideas about her
that'd be interesting
well i mean the other one was ed's wife
but that sort of seems like it's it's
negated now you know i mean there's no
real need to have ed again where judge
pompadumian
or whatever that name is
yeah but that seems also like you know
what what would we really what kind of
major court
engagement would there be now you know
what i mean yeah
yeah true
yeah i got it
lalo again marco wore a suit he's gonna
go and yeah this is what we were saying
marco wore suit in his last scam and
died do you think a similar fate for
gene also season one final called marco
will this be
i finally be called polo
uh that would be kind of cool i i don't
think so but um
i guess we we kind of put together what
you were saying in your last chat and
i don't i i
i don't think that that that's a
one-to-one foreshadowing but it could
look like that if if gene does end up
dying
which i also don't think is going to
happen
i'm still i'm still very confused as to
why they uh changed up the uh the title
stick that they were doing with the
blank and blank and why they went with
nippy and if the next episode is the one
that walt and jesse are in why didn't
they name it breaking bad
like come on
i don't know i always liked the idea of
saul's first episode in breaking bad
it's called better call saul walt and
jesse's first episode and better call
saul should be called breaking bad i
like it maybe it's a bit too obvious but
they already practically confirmed that
they're in the next episode anyways so
if they were going to confirm it ahead
of time they could have just called it
breaking bad
yeah there's no reason for them to use a
fake name just to hide the fact that
they were going to call it breaking bad
so
it doesn't seem like it's going to
happen i don't think that would be
terrible i i do like the idea of
you know them being
a team or a couple in a relationship so
all the titles that that when they're in
it together they're ands and whenever
they're split up it's a one word it's a
solo
but that's not even confirmed to be what
their thinking was that's just the logic
of it insomniac 117 thank you for the
ten dollars i think the way we will see
walt and jesse is through hidden
recording of walt and jesse remember
when saul had mike bug his place
maybe he would use this
to
period get a lighter sentence um
what do you think he's gonna rat out
walt and jesse somehow
i don't i don't
i don't know if he's gonna do that
yeah i mean i think it's possible that
it could be a hidden recording like
where you know saul's listening to them
or something like that but i i don't
know
i don't think it's about evidence like i
said i don't really care to
see him uh
go through a court case if that's his
decision
yeah agreed
um
here we go
tricycle jesus thank you for the zar 35
why did mike et cetera care to clean up
the howard mess
how would it have traced back to them if
they didn't
um
i mean i think that because that
you know jimmy and kim know them and
they could implicate them if they didn't
help them out right
yeah i think it was either they help
jimmy and kim out with the howard mess
and get them to keep quiet or they'd
have to kill jimmy and kim as well
yeah that's if that's the choice it's
it's easier to just
help them get rid of howard
and i mean if they killed jimmy and kim
they'd have to get rid of all the bodies
anyways so why not just get rid of i'm
saying you have two bodies you have two
bodies and two stories to come up with
and that yeah why make it four
yes i'm saying it's just more efficient
to just get rid of one right
yeah
thomas bark thank you for the s e k 20.
do anyone know episode when bob had
heart attack it was in 608 um
it was in between scenes and if you go
listen to the insider podcast they talk
about
they did all the they shot all the
footage of jim and kimmy or kim and
jimmy in the uh
the scene where you know they're talking
to to lalo and they were getting they
were on break and they were waiting for
to set up to shoot from the other side
to set up all the cameras to shoot
lala's stuff
and that's when it happened so they had
to come back in like months later just
like that that scene was shot over um
you know there was a two-month break in
the middle of it
yeah so they did all the jimmy and kim
scenes first then they had to wait six
weeks and then
uh tony dalton came back and did all of
his side of all the scenes but the thing
that confused me is that
uh in between 608 and 609 bob odenkirk
apparently did an article interview
where he said that he had the heart
attack in 609 but he might have i don't
know if he means that
they
it was that when they did some scenes
you know around him because they had to
shoot out of order because i know that
they did scenes that didn't involve
bob or jimmy while he was resting and
recovering and then he came back and
they did it um
but yeah i'm fairly certain that he was
in 608 so i don't really know what that
article interview was about about bob
saying it was in 609 but we heard the
whole story in great detail during the
608 podcast with them yeah you know
reviving bob odenkirk right on set with
the defibrillators so that was like a
whole thing
yeah it definitely um it definitely
happened in 608 it didn't happen while
he was who was actually acting and um
it's pretty wild to think about they
shot that scene on two different on you
know so far apart
um
okay another one from wallow salamanca
himself two dollars thank you the writer
said they're going real dark with mike
yeah i saw a post about this earlier um
you know that there was a question of
like
peter gould said gus would find love
they finally showed that in the last
episode
um
and then mike going real dark has mike
gone real dark already or you think
there's something more coming there
i think there could be something more
coming in the breaking bad timeline he's
definitely a dark person and breaking
bad
but i mean do you think that it's do you
think that we haven't seen him go dark
yet i mean that's the question you know
um
well to be honest we haven't really seen
mike uh have we seen mike even kill
anyone in season six well i mean you
know he he's talking he has this code of
like i'm not going to you know people
are in the game i'm not him you know he
he knows after talking to manuel that
like
yeah
it's just like kim uh kim and jimmy you
know like
he can have his code all he wants but
he's still people are still gonna get
hurt and die that don't deserve it and
he's a part of that and he makes a
choice so that's how we see him
different through breaking bad now is
like we know that he that he understands
that that is that his code's all really
just kind of [ __ ] but he does it
anyways because
that's what he's decided to do right
yeah i get i guess the whole better call
saul timeline has kind of just crushed
his spirits in that regard it's
corrupted him enough that he's probably
just going to throw that
you know that code to the sideline and
that's when he becomes a full uh hitman
for gus
yeah that's what i was thinking was like
he he actually has gone really dark at
this point compared to who he was when
we first met him and you know in season
one
right yeah that's definitely true
mark marcus thank you for the two
dollars the diamonds come up several
times any thoughts
uh i
i it seems like something they threw in
there that they could use later
it seems like it could be
a way for him to bug out you know with
some some cash that's easy to
that's small or whatever but um
lately the only thing that came up was
that that other teaser where he says you
know it sounds like he made a payoff it
could be part of the payoff
earlier chase brought up the idea that
he might give that to someone um
try to give it to kim but she might not
accept it
so yeah i
i don't think there's anything
i mean it's something it's something
that they put into the story they could
come back to but they haven't really
made it clear how they're going to come
back to it
i think it could totally just be a
machine gun in the trunk type of
situation you know yeah
and uh
i think i think if he does try to bribe
jeff it could be like a pinata situation
where he bribes them but then jeff does
come back and he's like oh you really
shouldn't have come back or you
shouldn't you should have just taken the
first deal and then he does something
bad to him
yeah
another mark barris think two dollars
thank you any thoughts on august
spin-off the waiter
well i think that the point of the scene
in uh
in the last episode was that the waiter
is is
something that he allows himself to have
that fantasy but he'll never follow
through on
so i don't think we'd see him come back
um
and i don't think that they were already
intimate i think they were just into
each other
and it was just you know just to show us
a different side of gus that they that
they kept hidden
so far
i i said that in the last stream we
talked about it got spin-off it would be
it would be fine i mean it would be it
would be okay uh i'm not dying to see it
but it would i'm sure it would be pretty
compelling
i mean i'd love to see it they might
have to do some serious de-aging or just
use a different action
they'd have to get a completely
different actor if they but yeah they
were gonna
yeah
yeah you could it's like you couldn't
make it you couldn't make an uh a young
mike series and and
as a cop or whatever
yeah yeah or chuck chuck in college and
have michael mckean back you know i mean
yeah i would watch it if they did it
because it would be
surreal but um i don't think you would
go into a series with that as your plan
yeah agreed
arie ozone thank you for the 499
thoughts on whether kim might head north
given ice station zebras meaning for her
plus
jessie's there
no i never really thought that that
seems a little contrived to me uh for
her to go to
alaska
what do you think chase
kim has absolutely no idea who jesse is
right unless she saw him on the news but
even so she'd have no idea that he's
there and it'd be a hell of a
coincidence for them to meet up
yeah i would agree and even if they did
they'd just be passers-by right it's not
like they'd suddenly
they
again thank you for five again if they
did the and title still then final
episode theory name wolves and sheep
well they could go back to the and
titles if they got back together um
i always liked the wolves and sheep
truth and consequences i don't know what
were some of your favorite uh and titles
that they never got around to
i've i've just been wanting a wolves and
sheep ever since 602. i thought that
that was for sure going to be a thing
but i totally forgot about it until now
i would like i'm just going to go with
wolves and sheep
yeah and
omega
i don't know
yeah the the fan the fake fan one that
was out there about the elements uh
what is it
something in bro brilliant
barium and her arium and brolium
whatever
i don't know
i'll have to reference the hail song
yeah my brain's starting to turn to mush
here
and that happens to coincide with the
this was the last one so we caught up to
the end um holy
three hours 17 minutes is long enough
for me i would like to thank everyone
who came out and asked questions
i'll throw that idea out there again if
you have if you want to get involved and
you may want to do some moderating give
me an email at the email you'll find on
the back end of my channel
chase do you want to
plug anything before we go
i'd just like to say maybe if we did get
a kim episode it would be called hanky
and dinky
[Laughter]
for real though i just did a uh gus
versus the cartel video up on my channel
where i talk about how they concluded
the better call saul cartel storyline
along with setting up the breaking bad
storyline check that out tomorrow i'll
have my 609 review up and i think on
monday i'm planning on trying to do a uh
kim's ultimate decision talking about a
breakup with jimmy before uh
before the new 610 episode comes out
that night so check that out i'll be
covering the next episode of course look
out for my season four tier list out
soon
no particular date but it's coming along
so look forward to that and uh yeah
thank you so much for having me on the
stream pete was a lot of fun a lot of
fun talking to eric and courtney as well
they're great
and uh yeah until next time right
yeah and you can find a uh you know the
links to his channel in the in the
description if you're not familiar and
um we're gonna end it there
maybe we'll be doing this again let me
know in the comments if you want to see
more saturday night
or if you think that's too much
and we'll be talking to you soon